la première fois aujourd'hui que des
élus de la République vont débattre de
ce recul de l'âge de départ à la
retraite puisque on le rappelle à
l'Assemblée nationale les députés
n'étaient pas parvenus jusqu'à cet
article 7 ce fameux article 7 de la
réforme des retraites merci merci
beaucoup Steve pour toutes ces
explications vous retrouve tout au long
de cette émission et oui depuis le début
de l'examen de ce texte la gauche et
dans une stratégie d'obstruction claire
frontale même si elle est bien plus
calme bien plus posée qu'à l'Assemblée
on entend beaucoup moins la droite qui
ne veut pas faire perdre de temps dans
les débats mais qui adoptent les
articles les uns après les autres
l'index seniors le CDI le Seigneur
l'ouverture vers une part de
capitalisation collective dans notre
système par répartition néanmoins la
droite sagace de la lenteur des débats
écoutez ce matin le président du groupe
LR au Sénat Bruno retaillod pas question
qu'on se laisse prendre en otage par une
volonté d'obstruction des oppositions
qui est des avis favorables défavorables
qu'on veuille voter contre c'est pas mon
cas mais je je comprends parfaitement et
ils sont dans le rôle de protester ils
sont dans leur rôle de s'opposer on est
aussi dans notre rôle vis-à-vis des
Français de vouloir aller au bout du
texte parce que je le dis aussi à la
gauche si vous voulez qu'on ne voit que
l'article 7 ça signifie que l'article 8
sur les travailleurs handicapés sur les
Invalides c'est pas important ça pour
les Français l'article 9 l'usure
professionnelle ceux qui ont durement
péné pendant toute leur carrière alors
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne doit pas
discuter et je suis à présent avec
Patrick canaire le président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat bonjour
Patrick canin votre réaction assez
propos de Bruno Retailleau qui dit il
n'y a pas question que la gauche prenne
le débat en otage est-ce que c'est ce
que vous faites aujourd'hui
le mot de prise en otage enfin nous
faisons notre travail de parlementaire
nous expliquons avec pédagogie
détermination ténacité ce que nous
voulons pas et c'est très fort nous
voulons pas et nous avons même proposé
hier toute une pour dire que cette
réforme pouvait se financer autrement
que par l'augmentation de l'âge légal et
tous ces amendements ont été refusés par
les amis politiques de Monsieur
Retailleau donc je pense que la première
obstruction c'est de refuser que une
autre voie est possible et elle est
portée par la droite cela vous dites que
c'est l'obstruction de la droite qui
refuse d'ailleurs de prendre par
la droite extrêmement silencieuse je le
regrette parce que ça mériterait les
débats alors bien sûr la droite est
aussi bloquée par le fameux article 47.1
de la Constitution qui limite le temps
de débat parce que c'est une loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
bien dans ces cas-là il pourrait être
avec nous pour dire au gouvernement on
ne veut pas de cette méthode On refuse
votre texte renvoyez-le en commission
renvoyez-le au gouvernement et nous
aurons un meilleur texte à défendre et à
présenter aux Français alors quel va
être votre stratégie sur cette ce fameux
article 7 est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
le débatte et bien cette nuit à un
moment où ça sera très difficile pour
les Français et bien d'écouter ce débat
ou dans les prochaines minutes comment
ça va se passer l'article 7 commencera à
être débattu en fin d'après-midi 18h un
petit peu avant un petit peu après nous
nous verrons bien donc nous sommes dans
un délai que je qualifierais de
raisonnable les Français ont manifesté
partout en France vous avez vu dans les
métropoles mais aussi dans beaucoup de
petites villes ça montre une forme de
colère qui est en train de monter et
donc ils vont pouvoir assister en
revenant chez eux et bien ce débat sur
sur l'article 7 je le souhaite avec
encore une fois cette ce souci de
pédagogique j'évoquais tout à l'heure il
faut que les Français sachent qu'il y a
deux projets de société qui sont en
train de s'affronter ici au Sénat les
Français sont opposés à la réforme mais
ils sont aussi fatalistes nous dit
certains sondages je pense que la
réforme sera adoptée malgré tout
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites est-ce que
je vois surtout c'est le cynisme du
gouvernement par rapport à ce qui peut
apparaître comme une contradiction en
disant mais on en veut pas mais le
gouvernement est obstiné le seul
problème c'est que si on passe en force
contre les Français ça laissera des
traces et si Monsieur Macron qui est à
l'initiative de toute cette affaire et
bien ne comprend pas que il devrait
écouter les Français il fait le lit
aujourd'hui le populisme et en
particulier de celui de l'extrême droite
Patrick canard la droite le gouvernement
ont toutes les armes parlementaires pour
faire adopter ce texte pour accélérer
sur ce débat d'ici dimanche pour le
faire voter qu'est-ce que vous espérez
pour que cette réforme ne soit pas votée
ce n'est pas possible normalement d'un
point de vue technique écoutez nous
avons nos amendements et il y a près de
mille amendements de mémoire sur le seul
article 7 nous prendrons une parole sur
article nous expliquerons nos voix nos
choix
si la droite sénatoriale veut nous
bâillonner veut nous bâillonner ça
serait le cas
l'article 38
de limiter le débat et bien je vais vous
dire
que la sincérité du débat parlementaire
manquerait pas aller jusqu'au bout et ce
sera peut-être au Conseil
constitutionnel et qui aura le soin de
le dire et de censurer ce texte est-ce
que votre objectif est toujours de ne
pas faire voter la réforme dimanche soir
le projectile je le répète c'est de voir
tous les articles dans de bonnes
conditions encore une fois c'est de la
responsabilité gouvernementale que
d'avoir limité le temps de débat au
travers de l'utilisation d'une loi de
finance dans rectificative de sécurité
sociale le premier obstructure le peuple
obstructeur permettez-moi l'expression
c'est le gouvernement je le dis je le
répète et si le gong sonne le 12 mars à
minuit et bien ni à l'Assemblée ni au
Sénat le texte aura été adopté comme
témoins de pensée complètement inédite
inédite mais du fait de qui encore une
fois il fait d'une forme d'obstination
et de certitude d'un seul homme le
président de la République nous sommes
dans un moment où il y a une sorte de
dialogue entre les parlementaires et les
manifestants on voit voilà la
mobilisation là aujourd'hui la
mobilisation de la gauche dans
l'hémicycle qu'est-ce que vous attendez
et bien aujourd'hui de l'intersyndicale
sur les prochains jours un certain appel
à un mouvement qui doit durer qu'une
grève reconductible certains appels à
des blocages certains appellent à mettre
l'économie à genoux notamment du côté de
la CGT
je dis simplement que l'intention
syndical a montré une très très grande
responsabilité une très très grande
unité et surtout
une fusion avec le peuple français qui
ne veut pas de cette réforme elle va
s'exprimer après la journée de ce 7 mars
nous tiendrons compte de cette volonté
exprimée ainsi mais le travail
parlementaire est à part et nous
continuerons notre travail ça ne fait
que commencer et si le gouvernement veut
passer en force et bien il s'opposera
non seulement la gauche politique mais
aussi aux Français dans leur plus grande
majorité est-ce que vous espérez de la
mobilisation dans la rue qu'on puisse
tomber sur un scénario comme 1995 ou
même comme sur le CPE ou par exemple et
bien Philippe Martinez l'a rappelé une
réforme a été adoptée mais finalement
elle n'a pas été appliquée elle n'a
jamais été promulguée parce que Jacques
Chirac qui quand même sentait les choses
avec compris que si le promulguait le
CPE et exactement
promulgame cette réforme du CPE aurait
été une bombe sociale dans le pays donc
il faut Macron comprenne que sa réforme
est mauvaise et qu'elle constitue
potentiellement aussi une bombe sociale
il faut qu'il réfléchisse merci beaucoup
notre canard d'avoir répondu à mes
questions et tout de suite et bien on
prend la direction de la séance ou les
discours les discussions se poursuivent
et vous nous l'avez dit il y a Patrick
canard et bien on n'est pas si loin de
l'article 7 peut-être d'ici une
demi-heure une heure on l'espère en tout
cas on prend la direction de l'hémicycle
et à condition d'avoir validé 44 années
de cotisation soit un an plus que les
salariés non bénéficiaires de ce
dispositif quant aux mesures
transitoires elles sont largement
insuffisantes pour maintenir les plus
âgées dans l'emploi le chômage des
seniors vous m'y apporter aucune réponse
si ce n'est des mesures cosmétiques qui
ne ridiront en rien la précarité des
plus de 55 ans en étendant la longueur
des années à attendre pour partir en
retraite vous étendez en réalité la
traversée du désert pour des milliers de
travailleuses et de travailleurs merci
le 36
74 même Vogel
oui merci madame la Présidente si vous
le permettez je vais défendre
l'amendement de ma collègue parce que je
pense que elle donne beaucoup Lucien et
qu'elle a besoin de prendre un petit peu
de salive pour continuer la suite donc
cet amendement propose de rajouter après
les mots améliorant les dispositifs de
prévention et de réparation de l'usure
professionnelle un élément de vérité qui
est que le
report de l'âge de départ de à la
retraite de deux ans
aggravera les problèmes d'usure
professionnelle
utégare à l'allongement de la durée de
travail de nombreux cotisants au sein
d'emploi pénible
par cet amendement le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire rappelle le
fait que reporter l'âge de l'égal de
départ à la retraite qui condamne de
nombreux actifs à travailler deux années
de plus et bien abîme les gens et qu'en
fait ça n'est pas très utile d'avoir
quelques petits pansements pour réparer
des personnes encore plus abîmées si le
projet principal que l'on défend c'est
une mesure qui va les abîmer davantage
si si vous voulez participer à ce que
les gens soient moins usés à ce que les
gens tombent moins malade au travail à
ce que le travail soit moins dur et bien
au lieu de faire travailler les gens de
deux ans de plus ce qui va les abîmer
deux ans de plus et on sait très bien
que la plupart des problèmes les arrêts
de travail entre 60 et 62 ans sont plus
nombreux qu'avant et bien simplement ne
les faites pas travailler plus longtemps
c'est la meilleure manière d'assurer que
le travail
use moins je vous remercie merci de 454
madame gréaume
notre amendement vise à corriger un
contresens il est écrit en effet dans
l'alinéa 10 de l'annexe que les
dispositifs compris dans la loi
amélioreront les dispositifs de
prévention et de réparation de l'usure
professionnelle de qui se moque-t-on le
recul de l'âge de départ à la retraite
de deux ans va dégrader au contraire de
la prévention et aggraver l'usure
professionnelle comment pourra-t-il en
être autrement non seulement les
solutions envisagées pour les métiers
pénibles comme le compte professionnel
de prévention sont extrêmement limités
de nombreux facteurs de pénibilité ne
sont pas pris en compte par cette
réforme les conditions de travail
exposants au port de charge lourdes aux
vibrations mécaniques ou encore aux
postures pénible ne permettront toujours
pas elle seule de partir plus tôt il y a
bien la création pour les métiers
identifiés par les branches comme les
plus exposées aux critères ergonomiques
d'un fond d'investissement dans la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
d'un milliard 3 milliards d'euros mais
quand se font sera créé et surtout quel
en sera son utilité alors non comme je
viens de vous le dire vous mesures
d'amélioreront pas les dispositifs de
prévention et de réparation de l'usure
professionnelle à les affaibliront comme
nous le dénonçons à travers cette
amendement que je vous demande d'adopter
merci merci le 4177 à même brûlant merci
madame la Présidente cette annexe expose
les effets de la réforme des retraites
en ce qui concerne la prévention et la
réparation de l'usure professionnelle en
termes plutôt élogieux mais
particulièrement faux si vous vouliez
véritablement améliorer les dispositifs
de prévention et de réparation de
l'usure professionnelle vous
commenceriez par réintégrer les quatre
facteurs de pénibilité que vous avez
retiré du compte personnel de prévention
de la pénibilité le c-3p ancêtre du C2P
compte personnel de prévention
aujourd'hui en vigueur quels sont-ils
ces critères manutention de charges
manuelle comme un échafaudeur par
exemple qui travaille sur les
plateformes industrielles de mon
département et qui m'explique porté
plusieurs tonnes par mois ce sont aussi
les postures pénibles comme celle de ces
aides-soignantes par exemple qui doivent
porter ou des placer des résidents en
EHPAD ce sont les vibrations mécaniques
subies par exemple par ses ouvrières de
l'agroalimentaire qui ont parfois le
sentiment qu'on se soucie plus du sort
des poulets qu'elle transforme que
d'elle-même l'exposition encore aux
agents chimiques dangereux et encore une
fois dans un département comme le mien
qui compte deux grandes plateformes
pétrochimiques on sait particulièrement
ce qu'il en est réintégré donc ces
critères faute de quoi vous serez
définitivement disqualifié pour dire que
cette réforme prévoit et prend en compte
la pénibilité je vous remercie merci le
3673 même pensé mange
même vos gènes
oui merci ma présidente alors là on va
arriver vous savez à ce grand débat il y
a combien de personnes qui vont passer à
1200 euros 40
000 puis après 20 000 et puis après
peut-être entre 10000 et 20000
13600 voilà c'est un conseil plutôt
monsieur le ministre vous auriez dû tout
simplement vous cantonnez à la mesure
c'est-à-dire à dire que
un certain nombre de personnes allaient
toucher une revalorisation allant de 0 à
100 c'est une de vos MInistres qui avait
dit ça et je trouvais ça intéressant
parce que de 0 à 100 sans le vouloir
elle a oublié de dire que pour beaucoup
c'était zéro
merci le 4157
la présidente assassine défendue
merci le 4160
défendu aussi
défendu le 4162 monsieur Bocquet
oui merci madame la Présidente une fois
encore nous vous présentons un
amendement de précision il y en a jamais
le trop afin d'apporter de la clarté à
nos compatriotes par rapport à ce projet
de loi en effet le minimum contributif
fait une protection nécessaire mais il
ne remplit pleinement son rôle de filets
de sécurité financière que pour les
carrières complètes or les retraités
pauvres le sont essentiellement du fait
de carrière incomplète et on pense bien
sûr en premier lieu aux femmes ne pas
préciser que ce dispositif exclura les
personnes ayant eu une carrière
incomplète serait une forme de mensonge
par omission c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous vous proposons d'inscrire
noir sur blanc que tous nos compatriotes
ne seront pas protégés par votre réforme
merci alors nous avons 11 amendements
identiques le 62 madame Pantel
merci madame la Présidente
le rapport qui figure un annexe au
projet de loi prévoit notamment une
hausse des taux des cotisations
vieillesse dues par les employeurs
publics à la Caisse nationale de
retraite des agents des collectivités
territoriales cette augmentation d'un
point de 2024 devrait représenter une
dépense supplémentaire pour les
employeurs territoriaux de quelques 460
millions d'euros par an
il est à noter que seuls les employeurs
publics sauf l'État lui-même auront à
contribuer financièrement à la réforme
puisque pour les employeurs privés cette
hausse sera compensée par une baisse des
cotisations à nous proposons de
supprimer cette hausse des cotisations
sociales pour les employeurs
territoriaux pour plusieurs raisons
cette hausse du taux de cotisation d'un
philobjet d'aucune concertation
préalable des employeurs publics elle
représente une double peine pour les
employeurs publics qui font déjà devoirs
qui vont déjà devoir assumer les
conséquences financièrement de
l'allongement de l'âge du départ à
retraite enfin toute variation du taux
de cotisation aurait dû avoir pour
préalable la remise à plat du système de
retraite des agents territoriaux
notamment du fait de la part croissante
d'emploi contractuels dans les
collectivités je vous remercie merci
Monsieur Bonhomme
merci de la présidente western en
demande concomitama au texte il est
prévu donc dans la trajectoire une
hausse de cotisation vieillesse due par
les employeurs publics à la cnr-rl
ça m'imprégée de l'opinion que chaque
employeur territoire peut porter sur
l'opportunité de report de l'âge de par
la retraite cette hausse immédiate du
taux de cotisation
n'a pas fait l'objet de concertation
après la des employeurs publics
rassemblés au sein de la coordination
des employeurs territoriaux laquelle a
clairement exprimé sur l'opposition à
cette mesure compte tenues notamment des
effets induits par la réforme du fait du
maintien prolongé une activité de leurs
agents le gouvernement s'est engagé par
courrier de la première ministre de
janvier 2023 a compensé intégralement
aux employeurs territoriaux cette hausse
de cotisation sans que le véhicule cette
compensation n'était à ce jour arbitré
il apparaît été confirmé aux
associations membres de cette
coordination lors d'une réunion du 13
février que il continuerait à moyen
terme être prélevé au titre de la
compassion démocratique vers les autres
régimes
dans ces conditions là de cotisation
d'un point de des employeurs affiliés à
la cnacl ne participera pas à
l'équilibre intrinsèque du régime et on
maintient de la compensation
démographique vers les hautes vers les
autres régimes de ce fait alors
financement indirect il convient donc de
revenir sur cette hausse de cotisation
ainsi la nécessité de ce prélable est
renforcée par l'intérêt d'examiner la
récente proposition de la CNA Racl en
faveur de l'élargissement de l'assiette
des agents qui sont affiliés
obligatoirement à cette caisse ou encore
par celui de questionner le seuil
d'affiliation à cette caisse
c'est amendement est soutenu par la
coordination des employés des employeurs
publics territoriaux instant informels
qui regroupe l'ensemble des institutions
nationales de l'île aux locaux
merci alors le 122 par Monsieur Lévy et
si vous pouviez parler un petit peu
moins fort sur ma gauche
merci il est défendu monsieur Levy merci
alors madame Nicolo
défendu merci ma Muller Braun
n'est pas là
monsieur le Président Madame le
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues cet amendement a pour
objectif de supprimer la hausse d'un
point des cotisations retraite des
employeurs de la fonction publique
territoriale et hospitalière inscrite
dans le texte à partir de 2024
cette hausse est une mauvaise surprise
et une mauvaise manière sans
concertation préalable dans la mesure où
le gouvernement s'était engagé à ne pas
toucher au cotisations sociales des
employeurs publics pour les associations
d'élus et notamment l'Association des
maires de France il s'agit d'une
aggravation financière pour les
collectivités puisque leur DGF déjà en
baisse subit avec l'inflation une
ponction de 500 millions d'euros et
voilà qu'on leur annonce une mesure qui
va coûter encore
460 millions d'euros supplémentaires par
an et qui aura évidemment des incidences
sur la capacité d'autofinancement des
communes et intercommunalité sur leurs
investissements et sur leurs projets
heureusement nous allons voter un
amendement des rapporteurs qui engagent
l'État à compenser cette hausse pour
autant les élus locaux pointent un
problème de confiance puisque le
gouvernement fait depuis le début le
contraire de ce qu'il avait dit et
qu'ils sont mis devant le fait accompli
d'ailleurs l'Association des maires de
France m'a encore confirmé ce matin
qu'ils auraient préféré une suppression
de cette hausse plutôt qu'une promesse
de compensation sans détails des
modalités
merci Monsieur Arnaud
est largement défendu au moment où je
parle je souhaite simplement
effectivement que à l'issue de
l'amendement proposé par le rapporteur
les rapporteurs on soit dans la
situation et la certitude et la garantie
qui n'aura pas un jeu de bon taux de
passe-passe entre effectivement la
garantie de la compensation telle que
elle nous est proposé par les deux
rapporteurs et le fait qu'il n'y ait pas
parallèlement une baisse de DGF où je ne
sais quelle vertu qui fasse au bout du
compte ce soit les collectivités locales
pas de manière directe comme proposée
dans le cadre du projet de loi actuel
mais de manière indirecte qui finance
une nouvelle fois cette cette nouvelle
hausse de cotisation à destination des
seuls employeurs publics je vous
remercie merci
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
ministre mesdames et messieurs
présidents et rapporteur vous voyez que
c'est amendement mission Luminy c'est
particulièrement important puisqu'il
vient de tous les bancs et de tout et de
tous les territoires alors moi je salue
le fait que la première ministre a dit
qu'elle compenserait cette hausse de
cotisation toutefois on a une situation
quand même un peu alambiquée puisque ce
régime de retraite qui concerne les
employés territoriaux et déficitaires et
va abonder le régime général donc nous
comme vous nous aimons bien la cohérence
et les comptes juste donc il y a un
problème je remercie les rapporteur pour
l'amendement qu'ils vont proposer
surtout messieurs les ministres je pense
qu'il faut réviser
l'assise du système de la scène Racl
puisque aujourd'hui
un contrat sur deux dans la fonction
territoriale et l'objet d'un contrat de
contractuel donc le système qui existait
précédemment ne tient plus donc on a la
moitié des nouveaux embauchés qui ne
cotisent pas à cette quête donc si on
peut mettre de l'ordre de la solidité de
la pérennité vous seriez ravis de tout
ça et nous encore plus merci merci
Monsieur Genet
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues après
avoir écouté les collègues depuis jeudi
dernier avec autant d'attention que de
patience je suis particulièrement
heureux de pouvoir m'exprimer quelques
secondes madame la Présidente en cette
journée du 7 mars et si j'ai acquis au
moins une conviction à vous écoutant
mais chers collègues c'est que le
pouvoir de conviction semble parfois
passer par la répétition donc vous
m'excuserez de répéter ce qui vient déjà
d'être dit précédemment par l'ensemble
de mes collègues en particulier par la
présidente de la délégation collectivité
territoriale et c'est vrai que pour
mettre échappé quelques heures hier soir
pour aller sierger au conseil municipal
de Digoin sur les orientations
budgétaires je peux vous dire que dans
beaucoup de communes qui préparent leur
budget messieurs les ministres les
conditions de dans lesquelles nous
pourrons boucler ces budgets sont
particulièrement inquiétantes parce que
se font toujours sentir bien sûr
l'explosion du coup de l'énergie et un
certain nombre de mesures sur les
ressources humaines avec le point
d'indice augmenté en juillet dernier et
ça va s'appliquer pour 12 mois en 2023
mais également un certain nombre de
mesures catégorielles et donc cette
hausse des cotisations serait vraiment
très malvenu et inquiète beaucoup nos
collègues élus locaux et donc c'est
pourquoi il est bon que vous puissiez
entendre cette opposition qui s'est
manifestée sur l'ensemble de ces bancs
et que vous puissiez prendre des
engagements réels sur le sujet je vous
remercie monsieur Tissot
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues au sein de
l'annexe de cet article 6 un rapport
décrit les prévisions de recettes et les
objectifs de dépenses par branche des
régimes obligatoires de base les
prévisions de recettes et de dépenses
des organismes concurrents au
financement de ces régimes ainsi que
l'objectif national de dépenses
d'assurance maladie pour les quatre
années à venir ainsi parmi ces
trajectoires il est prévu une hausse des
cotisations vieillesse dues par les
employeurs publics à la Caisse nationale
de retrait des agents des collectivités
locales la CNRS à hauteur d'un point et
c'est d'être et ceux des 2024 c'est
cette hausse du taux de cotisation on a
fait l'objet d'aucune concertation
préalable auprès des employeurs publics
rassemblés au sein de la coordination
des employeurs territoriaux ceci ont
clairement exprimé leur opposition à
cette mesure dans de nombreuses
communications ces derniers ont rappelé
qu'une approche globale devait être
privilégiée par rapport à une variation
du taux de cotisation décidé
unilatéralement par le gouvernement
avant toute décision trois enjeux
doivent être prises en compte et traités
celui de la compensation démographique
de la CNRACL vers les autres régimes
dont les employés le royaume demande la
suppression préalable celui de
l'équilibre de global des régimes de
retraite auxquels cotise des agents
territoriaux et enfin celui de la
réforme annoncée des parcours et
carrière des agents publics qui
pourraient conduire augmenter
substantiellement l'assiette de
cotisation et si votre gouvernement a
exprimé l'intention d'une compensation
financière intégrale de cette hausse
comme cela est proposé d'en amendement
21 16 des rapporteurs rien ne garantit
évidemment la pérennité de ses
compensations et les précédents
mécanismes mis en place en particulier
suite en particulier de suite à la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation ont
effectivement démontré que la
compensation promise n'était pas
toujours au rendez-vous je vous remercie
merci les 3416 même penser mon
bien en plus de tout ce qui a été dit
sur cet article je voudrais aussi
rappeler que comme d'habitude aucune
concertation préalable des employeurs
publics rassemblés au sein de la
coordination des employeurs territoriaux
a été a été faite par le gouvernement et
puis ensuite donc il n'a plus que
constater que cette mesure est
unanimement
ils sont unanimement opposés à cette
mesure dans un courrier du 25 janvier
donc la première ministre s'est engagée
à compenser intégralement auprès des
employeurs territoriaux cette hausse de
cotisation mais sans toutefois préciser
de quelle manière je voudrais rappeler
que ce sont certes les collectivités
territoriales mais c'est aussi la
fonction publique hospitalière et dans
l'état où elle est ce cette nouvelle
mesure est quand même est quand même
malvenue
d'autres mesures enfin d'autres voies
existent monsieur le ministre il s'agit
de cette
compris aux vraies causes du déficit des
caisses d'en finir avec les gels à
répétition des points d'indice des
fonctionnaires de stopper le
remplacement des fonctionnaires par des
contractuels ma collègue en a parlé et
puis aussi des intérimaires qui ne
cotisent pas à cette caisse les baisses
les effectifs les externalisations
représentent autant de problèmes de
budgétaire que d'atteinte au service
public dont on a pu en outre ces
dernières années constatées les
conséquences délétères
dans les hôpitaux c'est évident avec un
transfert des hôpitaux privés ou par
exemple un transfert de crèches
municipales vers les crèches privées
donc nous
notre groupe soutien
la suppression de la hausse de la hausse
d'un point des cotisations de cette
pièce merci de 4235 même Brûlins
merci madame la Présidente ça a été dit
cette augmentation de cotisations des
collectivités à la CNRS représenter 460
millions d'euros de dépenses
supplémentaires par an pour les
collectivités tout cela sans
concertation et je dirais même en total
des accords avec des associations d'élus
qui sont unanimes pour s'opposer à cela
drôle de manière de retisser la
confiance avec les collectivités je
voudrais réinsister sur l'injustice de
cette mesure parce que si les employeurs
publics les collectivités mais aussi les
hôpitaux ça vient d'être rappelé sont
soumis à cette augmentation de
collectivités les employeurs privés eux
ne le sont pas puisque leur cotisations
à la branche accident du travail maladie
professionnelle va être elle compensée
c'est une injustice flagrante alors on
nous explique qu'il faut équilibrer les
comptes de la CNRACL je ne reviendrai
pas sur ce qui a été dit là encore sur
le fait que le nombre de plus en plus
important de contractuels
ne cotisent pas à cette caisse et la
principale raison du déséquilibre de
cette caisse alors moi je veux bien
qu'on mise beaucoup sur les
compensations et nous aurons également
un amendement qui si celui-ci c'est ceci
n'était pas adopté demandera à l'état de
compenser mais je voudrais alerter nos
collègues ici d'abord sur le fait que
les élus savent ce qu'il en est des
compensations souvent promises mais
rarement au rendez-vous et enfin dans la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques comme dans l'article liminaire
du texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
même il est stipulé expressément que les
dépenses des collectivités territoriales
doivent diminuer de 0,6
. c'est ce que vous avez voté mes chers
collègues vous avez voté la loi de
programmation des finances publiques et
vous avez voté cet article liminaire
donc c'est bien que vous le regrettiez
d'ores et déjà et que vous proposiez de
supprimer cette cotisation mais liée les
actes aux paroles c'est encore mieux et
c'est ce que nous ferons pour notre part
si alors le 452 même plus Kerman oui
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues tout
d'abord on peut effectivement le
qualifier comme un amendement de repris
de repli pardon par rapport aux
amendements communs qui viennent d'être
défendus précédemment vous dire
peut-être tout de même mes messieurs et
ministre que je crois que ça commence à
suffire que systématiquement
il y a une forme d'acharnement je dirais
ainsi qui pèse en permanence sur le
budget de nos collectivités
territoriales dans ce pays
l'employeur que sont les collectivités
territoriales devient finalement celui
qui est le plus en difficulté on fait un
projet de réforme des retraites on
demande une hausse de cotisation en
l'occurrence ici pour la CNRACL on
revalorise les travail les salaires il
appartiendra au collectivité
territoriales de prendre en charge cette
hausse du point d'indice la situation
énergétique et nous en avons
suffisamment parlé ici fait que
finalement il faut prendre une grande
partie pour nombreux d'entre elles de la
hausse de l'énergie dans leur propre
budget et cela fragilise comme je l'ai
déjà dit finalement le service rendu à
la population alors cependant je ne
voudrais pas qu'il y ait de faux débat
comme certains l'ont laissé
sous-entendre lors de la commission des
affaires sociales bien évidemment nous
avons fait une intervention sur arctique
pour défendre les collectivités
territoriales j'ai défendu un amendement
pour défendre l'hôpital donc bien
évidemment loin de nous la volonté
d'opposer les collectivités
territoriales à l'hôpital public je le
dis puisqu'il apparemment certains s'en
sont émus et donc je demande une
modification de notre amendement pour le
rendre conforme à celui de Madame la
rapporteur en retirant en particulier
les collectivités territoriales même si
je pense que collectivement nous avons
une pensée très forte pour celle-ci
mais si le 2116 la commission des
affaires sociales même les rapporteur
oui je crois que sur tous les bancs nous
défendons les collectivités locales et
pas que parce qu'il y a tous les
établissements publics que ce soit les
établissements hospitaliers ou autres
mais pour reparler des collectivités je
sais combien vous êtes soucieux les uns
les autres dans cette période compliquée
où l'énergie coûte plus cher ou
l'alimentation coûte plus cher et où
finalement on a aussi ce qui a été
augmenté en termes de points d'indice
pour le personnel l'année dernière on a
tout ça en tête pour les collectivités
et donc ici dans cette chambre haute
effectivement on l'a vu à travers vos
propos il y a une prise directe et donc
c'est au niveau de la commission des
affaires sociales que nous avons voulu
aussi défendre les collectivités et
comme je le disais l'ensemble des
établissements publics c'est donc pour
cette raison que nous avons déposé cet
amendement et celui de Madame assassy
effectivement rectifié à l'identique
sera comme je le dirai tout à l'heure
j'y serai fav able pour la commission
le 4158
défendu merci madame la Présidente cette
annexe se pose les bases de l'analyse
des effets de cette réforme comme nous
l'avons déjà dit on ne peut en
conscience proposer cette réforme
injuste sans accorder d'importance à la
santé des travailleurs
or il est évident que cette réforme aura
des impacts sur la santé des Français en
ignorant la pénibilité en maintenant
dans la précarité plus longtemps des
sillons au chômage en grignotant un peu
plus les années de vie en bonne santé de
nos compatriotes cette phrase de la de
la lignée à 10 présente les enjeux du
rapport annexé au PLF RSS nous entendons
qu'elle intègre également la question de
la santé des Français confrontés à
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
selon le ministère de la santé il faut
savoir que 23% des Français souffraient
d'une limitation physique lors de leur
première année de retraite en 2018 les
plus touchés bien sûr sont les ouvriers
mais pas que un tiers des ouvriers et un
quart des employés sont dit en
incapacité lors de la première année de
retraite une étude réalisée publiée en
2021 au titre de l'évaluation des
politiques publiques stipule clairement
que le report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite tant augmenté significativement
la fréquence et la durée des arrêts
maladie notamment en raison de l'état de
santé des travailleurs en fin de
carrière
merci le 3675 même pensé mange
j'ai tellement
un Fernique c'est la fatigue
donc des chiffres absolument effarants
mais non moins réels sont apparus dans
le débat public à l'occasion de la
réforme des traits des retraites
actuellement c'est un quart des 5 % les
plus pauvres qui sont déjà morts à 62
ans et ce chiffre des hommes bien sûr ce
chiffre monta un tiers à 64 ans le
report de l'âge va donc aggraver les
inégalités sociales face à la mort
aujourd'hui les plus pauvres passent en
moyenne cette année de moins à la
retraite que les plus aisées la réforme
va donc leur prendre de nouvelles années
de vie à la retraite et creuser encore
plus la différence de vie à la retraite
entre les riches et les pauvres avec la
réforme ce sont donc chaque année les
statistiques sont implacables 9000
personnes supplémentaires qui auront
cotisé toute leur vie mais qui mourront
avant de pouvoir bénéficier de leur
retraite notre amendement vise donc à
mettre en lumière cette réalité dans la
loi afin que l'annexe visait à l'article
6 puisse refléter de façon plus juste
les effets réels de la réforme sur la
vie des Françaises et des Français
au-delà des seules considérations
budgétaires et comptables
le 3489 même penser Monge
merci madame la Présidente oui alors cet
amendement vise à supprimer les mots la
normalisation progressive de la
situation sanitaire comme si les
perspectives financières de cette loi
allaient normaliser l'état de la
situation sanitaire dans notre pays en
réalité ce que ce que décrit ces
perspectives financières c'est pas du
tout qui va y avoir un retour à la
normale de notre situation sanitaire en
France c'est simplement que le
gouvernement a prévu de ne pas faire les
investissements nécessaires dans notre
système de santé pour qu'on puisse avoir
un service public de santé digne de ce
nom et donc dans les faits la situation
de l'hôpital public et de la santé
publique dans notre pays va se dégrader
alors vous pouvez appeler ça
normalisation progressive de la
situation sanitaire nous trouvons que ce
n'est pas vraiment l'expression
idoine et donc nous le retirons
d'accord merci beaucoup alors le 4165
nous interrompons quelques minutes le
débat alors que d'ici quelques dizaines
de minutes on devrait arriver à
l'article névralgique de ce texte
l'article 7 sur le report de l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite de 62 à 64 ans
car nous sommes avec la présidente du
groupe communiste au Sénat Eliana si
bonjour bonjour Eliane assassin on a
entendu pour nos retaillod ce matin dire
qu'il était prêt à accélérer les débats
on le sait la droite le gouvernement ont
des armes parlementaires pour pouvoir
accélérer le débat qu'est-ce que vous
leur dites aujourd'hui
dit qu'il devrait écouter ce qui s'est
exprimé aujourd'hui dans la rue on a vu
une manifestation parisienne moi j'ai
fait les trois précédentes
grandiose aujourd'hui à l'évidence il
s'est passé aussi des choses dans les
petites villes les moyennes villes les
grandes villes de de hors Paris donc je
dis attention attention la colère est
très forte dans le pays l'exigence du
retrait de cette réforme monte de plus
en plus donc il faut savoir écouter ce
qui se dit dans la rue dans la rue ce
sont des gens ce sont des nos
concitoyens et nos concitoyens donc il
faut savoir les entendre majoritairement
les gens ne veulent pas de cette réforme
et des millions l'expriment encore
aujourd'hui dans la rue mais vous le
voyez une véritable contraste entre ce
qui peut se passer au Sénat ou la droite
est majoritaire et ce que l'on voit dans
la rue puisque les différents points du
texte qui ont précédé ont été adoptés
les uns sur les autres à l'index senior
le CDI ça n'empêche pas ça n'empêche pas
les mobilisation
malgré le vote de mesure
qui sont attentats attentats au droit de
nos concitoyens nos concitoyens il y a
des millions de gens aujourd'hui dans la
rue donc ils devraient un petit peu
entendre que malgré ses votes là la
colère est toujours là mais non
seulement elle est là mais elle
s'exprime encore plus fortement donc
vous voyez c'est c'est leur silence dans
l'hémicycle est assourdissant le silence
de la droite et des centristes états sur
10 ans
c'est quand même incroyable qu'il soit
aussi comment dire éloigner de ce que
pense le peuple aujourd'hui de notre
pays sur cette réforme c'est quand même
assez incroyable parce que après tout ce
sont des élus ils ont des électeurs
qu'ils soient sédataires ou qu'ils
soient et élus élus locaux donc quand
même il devrait l'entendre ce message
j'avoue j'avoue que je ne les comprends
pas et pour venir à votre première
question moi je dis chiche qu'ils
utilisent des procédures mais je peux
vous dire que en priorité les
amendements
du Sénat a des procédures réglementaires
qu'il a à sa disposition donc je sais
que le gouvernement a le petit frère du
49-3 aussi à sa disposition c'est tout
ça on n'est pas naïf on a examiné en
2010 donc on a mis toutes les hypothèses
dans sur la table mais tout ça ne ne
créera pas des conditions qu'on se
baigne
qu'on se bâillonne aujourd'hui non on
continuera à porter nos propositions et
même si des procédures sont déclenchées
on peut défendre nos amendements donc on
défendra nos amendements c'est ça que
votre stratégie sur l'article 7 il y a
presque 80 amendements de suppression
aujourd'hui vous allez vous battre tout
à fait nous voulons nous voulons la
suppression majeure article et nous
voulons que cet article soit soumis au
vote des sénatrices et des sénateurs
chaque française et chaque Français a le
droit de savoir ce que son parlementaire
a voté est-ce qu'il est pour la réforme
ou contre la réforme vous l'avez dit
l'article 7 c'est le cœur du réacteur
donc c'est un vote très important donc
nous nous tenons au débat et aux votes
sur cet article 7 vous tenez au vote sur
cet article 7 est-ce que vous tenez au
vote sur l'ensemble du texte dimanche 12
mars sincèrement derrière l'article 7 il
y a des articles encore 13 ans 13 ans
sur les 1200 euros sur la pénibilité
enfin etc donc on va on va aussi faire
ce que nous faisons depuis le début de
l'examen de ce texte c'est-à-dire que
nous allons défendre nos amandes avec
des propositions alternatives ça prendra
le temps que ça prendra y compris s'il y
a recours à des à des procédures donc si
le texte n'est pas terminé dimanche soir
à minuit et ben il ne sera pas terminé
dimanche soir à minuit ça vous poserait
pas de problème vous le souhaitez moi
non ça ne me posera aucun problème je
suis en phase avec ce que les gens
disent dans la rue justement
dans la rue et bien la manifestation est
importante aujourd'hui
la CGT parle de 700 000 manifestants
dans le cortège parisien bon on n'a pas
encore
les les chiffres d'occurrence ou du
gouvernement euh qu'est-ce que vous
attendez des prochains jours puisque on
entend des appels conduite
je ne suis pas une organisation
syndicale donc je laisse le soir aux
organisations syndicales de décider
quels seront les suites des de de cette
mobilité mobilisation pour exiger le
retrait de ce texte donc on verra il
doit se réunir me semble-t-il en fin
d'après-midi je me demande même s'ils ne
sont pas déjà et donc on verra ce qu'il
décideront et nous nous prolongerons en
fait les décisions qui seront prises par
par l'intersydical nous n'avons pas à à
nous comment dire à interférer dans
les travaux de
l'intersyndical ils vont se réunir
prendre des décisions et nous nous
allons prolonger d'un point de vue
politique
ce qu'il décideront de faire est-ce que
vous vous reconnaissez dans ceux qui
sont dans une certaine radicalité qui
disent qui sont prêts à mettre la France
à genoux on peut attendre et c'est quoi
la radio
c'est quoi la radicalité c'est quoi la
radicalité vous savez moi il y a des
mots comme ça qui me chiffonnent
obstruction pour parler de Parlement le
radicalité
on est dans d'autres rôles de
parlementaires il y a un texte on y
opposé on fait des propositions
alternatives on n'est pas dans
l'obstruction voilà on est on est ce que
nous sommes une gauche d'opposition et
qui propose voilà c'est pas de
l'obstruction ou alors on rentre chez
nous que si vous voulez que je vous dise
moi et et et et donc voilà on en est là
et radicalité ça veut dire quoi
radicalité il y a des mots comme ça qui
émergent dans l'espace public qui font
peur aux gens
qui crée de la confusion qui sont
limites anxiogènes et pourquoi il y a
pas de radicalité regardez toutes les
manifestations ce sont déroulées
tranquillement qu'est-ce qu'on attend
qu'est-ce qu'on attend qu'il fait à
Paris pour que le gouvernement nous dise
voyez c'est les mobilisations les
syndicats ne tiennent rien non tout se
passe bien comme je l'ai dit en séance
vous aviez pas tout va bien se passer
voilà
bien merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
répondu à mes questions alors qu'on
attend allez dans quelques dizaines de
minutes peut-être cet article 7 qu'on a
ne finit pas d'attendre merci beaucoup
Hélène assassin d'avoir répondu à mes
questions on va tout de suite rejoindre
l'hémicycle c'est l'art porteur général
de la commission des affaires sociales
Elisabeth donne qui est en train de
s'exprimer
à la demande d'un temps choisi qui soit
mieux qu'un temps qu'un temps partiel et
aussi de répondre à cette pénibilité que
vous évoquez pour certains
je pense qu'il faut réfléchir
effectivement à tout ça et on aura
l'occasion dans un des articles de le
faire puisqu'il y a ce fameux fond
d'usure professionnelle et c'est et
c'est mon collègue qui vous en parlera
comme il y a aussi le fond de prévention
qui est très intéressant on a pu
entendre d'ailleurs les deux personnes
qui sont en charge de ce dossier et donc
en tout cas vous avez effectivement
parlé de beaucoup de sujets intéressants
nous proposons en revanche de donner un
avis favorable madame la Présidente à la
nécessaire actualisation par le
gouvernement des objectifs de dépenses
de recettes et de soldes des régimes
obligatoires de base de la sécurité
sociale et en conséquence le
rehaussement de l'ONDAM 2023 et c'est
donc un avis favorable à l'amendement du
Gouvernement 47 22 et pour tous les
autres un avis défavorable
merci beaucoup la vie de gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente en essayant
d'aller aussi vite que possible mais il
y a évidemment beaucoup de sujets qui
ont été abordés des sujets d'importance
je vais m'arrêter sur le sujet de la
cnr-a-cl donc je sais qu'il a beaucoup
fait parler certains ont fait référence
à la conclusion en cours des budgets
dans les collectivités locales j'étais
moi-même en conseil municipal il y a
quelques semaines dans le conseil
municipal où je siège depuis 10 ans je
fais partie des membres du gouvernement
qui sont aussi élus locaux on avait la
discussion sur le débat d'orientation
budgétaire je siège dans l'opposition
dans ma commune donc j'ai été interpellé
par le maire sur la hausse de
cotisations
CNRACL et donc j'ai eu l'occasion de lui
dire un certain nombre de choses en
primeur du coup mais je vais vous les
dire ici évidemment d'abord la cnr-a-cl
est en déficit de manière importante
à horizon 2030 c'est 8,4 milliards
d'euros de déficit c'est-à-dire 62% du
déficit total de notre système de
retraite pourquoi parce que la STMR ACL
connaît de façon plus forte encore que
les autres régimes le déséquilibre
démographique il y avait quatre
cotisants pour un retraité cnr-cl en
1990 c'est aujourd'hui 1,5 cotisants
pour un retraité donc on est en dessous
du ratio démographique tout régime à
partir de là à chaque fois qu'il y a eu
des réformes des retraites des réformes
paramétriques en 2003 en 2010 en 2014
elles ont conduit à résorber une partie
du déficit de la CNRACL le fait de
travailler plus longtemps par définition
a aussi un impact à la baisse sur le
déficit de la CNRACL et elles se sont
toutes accompagnées de hausse de
cotisation CNRS de hausse de cotisation
employeur j'ai entendu notamment sur
certains bancs accusés le gouvernement
d'attaquer les collectivités locales
parce qu'il y aura une augmentation du
taux de cotisation CNRACL je veux
rappeler quand même que sous le
quinquennat de François Hollande
2012-2017 tous les ans il y a eu des
hausse de cotisations CNRACL pour les
employeurs territoriaux de 1,5%
certaines années du même plus de 1,55 %
certaines années il y a une différence
entre les hausse de cette époque et
celle que nous faisons c'est que les
hausses précédentes de cotisation CNRAC
quelles étaient portées par des
gouvernements de droite ou de gauche
n'ont jamais été compensés aux
collectivités locales c'est la première
fois qu'un gouvernement s'engage à
compenser une hausse de cotisations
CNRACL au collectivité locale ça mérite
quand même d'être souligné puisque avant
les cotisations augmentaient tous les
ans sous certains quinquennat jamais de
compensation nous on pense voilà et donc
très concrètement qu'est-ce qui va se
passer
passer d'abord le recul de l'âge légal
de départ de deux ans a un impact sur le
déficit de la CNRACL il va réduire le
déficit de la cnr-a-cl d'un milliard
deux à horizon 2030 ensuite on propose
une hausse de cotisation d'un point je
précise quand l'absence de réforme et si
on voulait combler le déficit de la
cnr-a-cl à horizon 2030 uniquement par
de la hausse de cotisation il faudrait
l'augmenter de 12 points 12 points de
hausse de cotisation on fait un point de
hausse de cotisation 700 millions
d'euros et on le compense aux
collectivités locales c'est l'engagement
qu'on a pris j'ai réuni avec mes
collègues Stanislas Guérini et Dominique
Faure les associations d'élus les
employeurs territoriaux on a une longue
réunion avec avec eux de plusieurs
heures je leur ai dit que j'étais ouvert
sur les modalités de compensation et que
je souhaitais les travailler avec eux
il y a plusieurs possibilités soit on
fait un prélèvement sur recettes en PSR
soit on passe par la DGF soit on fait ce
qu'on appelle un swap de taux c'est à
dire un échange de taux avec les
cotisations familles j'ai dit aux
associations des lieux aux employeurs
territoriaux je vous laisse travailler
ces différentes pistes on est prêt à
vous donner des précisions sur les
différents scénarios et on choisira
ensemble la manière dont on compense
cette hausse de cotisation on doit se
revoir dans les prochaines semaines et
donc on avancera avec eux donc tout ça
pour dire que je suis défavorable aux
amendements qui proposent de revenir sur
la hausse de cotisations puisque ça
serait un mauvais coup porté à la CNRACL
dont on a quand même besoin d'appuré le
déficit et la dette que par ailleurs la
hausse de cotisation s'accompagne d'une
compensation par l'État ce qui est
inédit dans notre histoire et donc que
je donne un avis favorable aux deux
amendements assis
et Doisneau donc le 45 02 Regis et le 21
16 vous noterez que voilà après hier
soir c'est un autre amendement venant
des bancs de la gauche auquel on donne
un avis favorable il y a donc une vraie
ouverture de notre part de notre part
donc voilà mais je m'en vais bientôt
comme le dit Olivier du soft donc pas de
chance
je donne un avis défavorable aux autres
amendements et évidemment un avis
favorable par principe au 47 22 du
gouvernement
merci alors comme nous avons beaucoup
d'amendements pour les
demandes de d'explication de vote je
vais appeler les amendements et vous me
direz sur lequel vous vous parlez sauf
si c'est général auquel cas je vous
donne tout de suite la parole
monsieur Jomier c'est sur la totalité
c'est à dire c'est juste sur un
amendement madame la Présidente sur
celui du gouvernement c'est tout donc ça
va être court puisque sur les autres on
va pas se répéter
le gouvernement donc modifie de 600
millions l'enveloppe de l'hôpital et de
150 millions celle de la ville sur
l'hôpital donc j'en ai parlé ce sont ces
destinés manifestement de ce qu'on
comprend du cours texte qui nous a été
transmis à proroger des mesures de
revalorisation très bien mais ça ne
prend toujours pas en compte l'inflation
le niveau de l'inflation 2023 qui est
supérieur à ce qui était attendu donc
c'est un premier problème sur la ville
150 millions là on avait un nom d'âme à
plus de 9 dont on avait pointé qui
portait un carcan qui allait rendre très
compliqué les accords avec les
professionnels de ville et si tu devais
arriver arriva c'est l'échec des
négociations conventionnelles ça fait
très longtemps qu'on n'a pas vécu cette
situation dans notre pays et il faut pas
chercher beaucoup plus loin
de la cause la cause de cet échec voilà
et puis dernier point moi je me félicite
que le gouvernement donc en mettant dans
un PLFSS rectificatif une modification
de 750 millions de Londres prend acte
que c'est légitime et donc nous
attendons que les années ultérieures les
modifications d'un tel niveau de l'âme
face effectivement l'objet d'une loi de
finance sociale rectificative qui soit
présenté à la commission des affaires
sociales et donc nous voterons
l'amendement du Gouvernement merci donc
même vos gel et Monsieur Breuillet c'est
sur la totalité aussi même vos gel en
premier
merci madame la Présidente c'est pas sur
la totalité c'est sur un amendement mais
je vous donne le numéro c'est le 36 73
de ma collègue Raymonde poncer mon je
voulais juste dire donc c'est
l'amendement qui consiste à préciser
dans l'annexe que le nombre de personnes
en France qui vont être touchées par la
hausse de la retraite à 1200 euros
s'élève entre 10 et 20 000 le
Gouvernement et la commission ont donné
un avis défavorable à cet amendement et
je voudrais dire que pour une fois
plutôt d'accord avec le gouvernement
avec la Commission et je suis désolé
Raymonde mais je pense effectivement
qu'ils ont qu'ils ont un point là
puisque comme dirait l'un il faut avoir
l'humilité de dire qu'il y a eu du
flottement
peut permettre excusez-moi de vous
montrer un petit graphique ça c'est le
nombre de personnes a priori concernée
par les 1200 euros de retraite minimale
depuis le début de la Réforme donc là on
est le 10 janvier on a environ quatre et
demi millions de personnes qui croient
qu'elles vont avoir une retraite minimum
à 1200 euros pour toutes et tous une
fois que la réforme aura été adoptée je
sais que je
c'est un graphique qui reprend les
données du gouvernement je crois pas que
ce soir insultant si vous voulez trouver
insultante ça vous regarde je vous
remercie donc là on est le 10 janvier le
15 février monsieur dussobe sur France
Inter nous dit en fait ce sera 40 000
personnes de plus chaque année
le 28 février c'est en fait entre 10000
et 20000 donc tu vois Raymond on est ici
mais là comme en fait on n'est plus le
28 février on est le 7 mars on doit être
vers là donc je pense que c'est plutôt
7000 et en fait je ne sais pas à combien
on sera quand on aura fini le vote et
pour cette raison vous me permettrez de
préciser à ma collègue vraiment que je
suis désolée mais je vais m'abstenir sur
cette amendement je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Breuillet
oui on va interrompre quelques instants
les débats on va rejoindre Steve
Jourdain car nous sommes maintenant à
quelques minutes de cet article 7 que
nous n'en finissons pas d'attendre Steve
on finit pas d'attendre on est
actuellement effectivement sur l'article
6 c'est un article extrêmement technique
puisqu'il parle et bien de la
trajectoire budgétaire de cette réforme
des retraites mais ne zappez pas ne
bougez pas rester sur public sinon je
vous promets mais dans quelques instants
une séquence beaucoup plus politique
beaucoup plus binaire en quelque sorte
beaucoup plus clivant puisque les
sénateurs vont devoir répondre à une
question très simple qui est pour qui
est contre le recul de l'âge de départ à
la retraite ils vont effectivement vous
l'avez dit à m'examiné l'article 7 de
cette réforme je peux d'ores et déjà
vous faire une petite bande annonce un
petit teaser de ce qui va se passer on
va voir une gauche remonter à bloc
contre cet article 7 la gauche on
rappelle ici au Sénat est composé de
trois groupes il n'y a pas de nupestres
il y a trois différents groupes les
écologistes les socialistes et les
communistes ils ont déposé plusieurs
milliers d'amendements sur ce seul
article
7300 amendements au total et sur ces
1300 amendements et bien il y en a 77
qui sont des amendements dit de
suppression c'est-à-dire des amendements
qui viennent dire niet non au recul de
l'âge de départ à la retraite de l'autre
côté de l'hémicycle la droite le groupe
LR devrait être beaucoup plus sage au
moment d'examiner bien cet article 7 il
va falloir voir comment ils vont réagir
aux prises de parole de la gauche est-ce
qu'ils vont défendre pieds à pied cette
réforme lancée par Emmanuel Macron c'est
une position pas très simple pour le
groupe LR une position en quelque sorte
d'équilibriste et eux qui veulent et
bien se distinguer d'Emmanuel Macron on
va voir comment ils vont réagir beaucoup
avaient annoncé la fin du clivage
droite-gauche devrait être démenti ce
soir Tam merci merci beaucoup Steve pour
toutes ces explications et en attendant
et bien on reprend la direction des
débats dans l'hémicycle là on voit bah
c'est les écologistes qui s'exprimer
c'était Daniel Bruyer et puis voilà
parce qu'elle connaît qui reprend la
parole la vis présidente du Sénat qui
préside la séance
un chef de fil des écologistes qui
s'exprime à présent
c'était un peu optimiste effectivement
je le concède quant à mon collègue
Daniel j'avais lui demander la formule
latine pour moi aussi rappeler au
ministre que je lui demande de retirer
les 3 milliards qu'il a mis indument
dans les mesures d'accompagnement de
cette réforme et qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être les mesures étant de 3 milliards
et de sites mais c'est pas pour ça que
j'intervenais en plus c'est pour
répondre aussi à ce qui a été dit sur la
caisse des collectivités locales
monsieur le ministre vous dites à terme
en 2030 ça rapportera cette réforme
prise sur les travailleurs Daniel
Brunier vers le dire 1 milliard deux
d'amélioration donc de la caisse j'ai
posé la question aux responsable de
caisse des dépôts de consignation qui
gère séquestre
je lui ai demandé quelle avait été
l'effet du Ségur de la santé
c'est à dire des salaires versés les
primes les augmentations de salaire etc
donc des cotisations sur la caisse il
m'a dit et bien ça a donné un an moi
j'avais 850 millions et je voulais lui
demander si 850 millions étaient exact
il m'a dit effectivement ça a donné un
an de détente à la caisse ça a donné en
fait le même effet que votre réforme
donc plutôt que votre réforme je vous
propose de doubler ce que vous avez fait
pour le Ségur de la santé merci Madame
vermillier
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
intervenir donc concernant cette hausse
de points CNRACL alors moi j'avais
déposé un amendement concernant cpeos
mais il se retrouve à l'article
additionnel après l'article 13 je pense
que c'est plus important de d'intervenir
à cet instant cette hausse de points
prévoit de rapporter 600 millions par an
jusqu'en 2028 pour compenser une partie
du déficit CNRACL et puis 700 millions à
partir de 2028 or lacération du fait de
son déséquilibre démographique
elle est malgré tout aujourd'hui
contributrice nette au régime des
compensations démographiques et elle
contribue aujourd'hui à hauteur des 670
millions par an
je pense en termes de méthode qu'il
aurait été plus simple de supprimer la
contribution de la CNRACL à cette
contribution démographique et ne pas
procéder à cette hausse CNRS que Madame
la rapporteur vous proposait un
amendement le gouvernement va compenser
très bien mais si on doit revoir dans un
prochain tlfss ces contributions nettes
aux compensations démographique on
s'apercevra effectivement qu'il n'est
plus justifié que la CNRACL fasse ses
contribution démographique elle sera
sans doute revue dans l'ensemble des
contributions démographiques le
principal contributeur étant la CNAV
aujourd'hui avec plus de 4 milliards
mais on s'apercevra que cette
contribution n'est plus vraiment due par
la scénaire à ciel le problème c'est que
la hausse du point elle aura eu lieu et
c'est ça va être à mon avis très
compliqué je doute que dans les années
qui viennent on revienne sur cette
hausse de taux donc en termes de
méthodes moi je veux bien que le
gouvernement compense il y a pas de
problème mais ça aurait été plus simple
de se rendre à l'évidence l'accinération
elle n'a plus lieu de compenser des
compensations démographiques ainsi
monsieur le rapporteur
juste une précision on a déjà eu
l'occasion de s'en entretenir c'est
madame le rapporteur général qui s'est
occupé de cette question là il n'empêche
qu'il y a effectivement des différences
par rapport à la somme des caisses
puisque cette caisse de crsl a une
cotisation patronale à hauteur de 34 %
déjà c'est quand même important quand on
sait que le privé aux alentours de 28%
mais le public les caisses de l'État
sont plutôt aux alentours de
74%. donc un jour ou l'autre ça fait les
équilibres dans le dispositif et c'est
pour ça que certains disent derrière que
on cache 30 milliards d'euros qui
alimenteraient le dans les rapports du
corps qui alimenteraient le système de
retraite non c'est selon les
compensations et si on touche à la
compensation démographique qui est
effectivement un sujet d'ajustement en
fonction de la démographie de chacun des
régimes mais il faut toucher à tous les
régimes faut pas toucher qu'à la cnrsl
donc ça mérite une réflexion approfondie
car c'est vrai récompense tout en étant
déficitaire parce qu'elle était sur une
progression de son nombre de cotisants
que maintenant elle est au contraire sur
une diminution du nombre de cotisants
c'est une bonne question mais elle
mérite une analyse plus précise c'est la
raison pour laquelle la rapporteur
général n'a pas retenu cette proposition
merci alors je vais mettre au bois alors
tout d'abord
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres monsieur les présidents
importants juste sur l'ensemble des
amendements moi je voudrais saluer
l'intelligence et la finesse du
raisonnement de notre collègue vermillet
il me semble que si tu étais plus simple
de ne pas procéder à des augmentations
ce qui aurait évité des contributions
bref je vous invite messieurs les
ministres à réfléchir à cette bonne
suggestions merci à Madame assis ses
collègues et aux rapporteur pour
l'amendement mais monsieur le ministre
il y a un point auquel vous n'avez pas
répondu je pense qu'on a un problème de
déficit démographique puisque
aujourd'hui je l'ai dit dans mon
amendement on a la moitié des personnels
des collectivités qui sont embauchés
comme contractés donc qui ne cotise pas
alors même qu'on a une masse de gens à
partir donc monsieur le ministre j'ai
bientôt nous quitter mais moi je vous
propose un devoir du soir la question de
Madame vermillier et puis celle de
l'élargissement de la base du système de
CNRACL et je retire mon amendement
madame
oui monsieur le ministre
notre cours parce qu'effectivement
j'avais pas répondu à ce point merci
d'avoir retiré votre amendement ça fait
partie des discussions qu'on a eu avec
les employeurs territoriaux et qu'on a
par ailleurs avec la CNR Racl on a parlé
de une remise à plat du système parce
que comme vous l'avez dit vous avez de
plus en plus de contractuels qui par
définition de cotise pas à la cnrcl ce
qui contribue au déséquilibre
démographique donc il y a une remise à
plat à faire qui va prendre un peu de
temps quand même c'est un chantier
d'ampleur mais on s'est engagé
évidemment à travailler sur ce point
avec les employeurs territoriaux et
évidemment aussi avec la représentation
nationale
merci alors donc je mets au foie
l'amendement de 1900 de Madame Lubin a
dit défavorable la Commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient pas adopté
pour l'amendement
3476 je suis saisie d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe écologiste
donc je vous rappelle la vie de la
commission est défavorable du
gouvernement défavorable il va être
procédé au creux d'un public dans les
conditions fixées par la
il est retiré
vous retirez le scrutin public vous
retirez l'amendement
le scrutin public
ce comptable veut dire que nous retirons
toutes les demandes
de scrutin public relative à l'article 6
d'accord merci beaucoup c'est plus clair
merci alors donc je mets aux voix donc
l'amendement 3476 donc du groupe
écologiste
avis défavorable donc du gouvernement de
la commission qui est pour qui est
contre qui ça tient n'est pas adopté
amendement de 1900 à Madame Lubin même
avis ce qu'on considère même vote oui
la maman 3641 impensé Monge même à vie
même vote le 3676 le 3678 le 3473 le
2897 de Madame Lubin même avec même vote
le 2902 également
4131 madame assassin
le 3667 madame poncemonge
m'arrêter on nous avait annoncé qu'il
allait y avoir une accélération dans les
débats on l'attendait constater déjà
qu'il y a un premier signe c'est que le
groupe écologiste vient de renoncer à
toutes ces demandes de scrutin public
sur cet article 6 et donc vous le voyez
ce sont des votes amanovés et qui se
font de façon à beaucoup plus rapide
parce qu'elle Grigny la vice-présidente
du Sénat peut donc enchaîner les votes
sur ces amendements qui ont déjà été
présentés les uns après les autres ont
rejoint tout de suite l'hémicycle à
présent
le 3176 tombent le 4148 de Madame
assassin même avis même vote le 2906
tombe le 4147 même assassin même avis
même vote deux amendements identiques
3499 même penser Monge 4175 madame
assassin
le
4141 de Madame assassin même avis même
vote le 3235 a même pensé Monge même
avis même vote le 3170 172 tombes le
3680 de Madame poncemonge même avis même
vote
4178 de même assassin le 4150 41502 4150
pour Simon je mets ma vie même vote
4154 4177 de même assassin même avis
même vote
3673 même penser mon je me la vie même
vote
4157 41 60 4162 de même assassin même à
vie même vote ensuite j'ai les
amendements 62 jusqu'à 4235 qui sont
identiques dont le 1125 vient d'être
retiré donc avec des favorable la
Commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ne sont pas adoptées nous
passons à deux amendements devenus
identiques le
452 il y a un scrutable d'accord donc le
452 de Madame assassin et le 2516 de la
commission avis favorable pour les deux
avis favorables qui pour qui contre qui
s'abstient sont donc adoptés le moment
4158 de Madame assassis après
quelqu'un demande la parole là non
donc le 4158 donc avec des favorable de
la commission et du gouvernement donc
qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient vous ne
suivez pas j'ai l'impression que ça va
pas bien assez le dérouleur c'est pour
ça que je donne à la fois le nom voilà
donc ensuite j'ai le 3175 3489 de Madame
ponce même a dit même vote
a été retiré bon
ensuite j'ai le 4165 41
mais ma vie même vote le 4180 même avis
même vote
4187 et 4188 tons et ensuite j'ai 4190
4169 4479 assassin même avis même vote
et les 4570 et le 4172 tombe
voilà alors maintenant nous passons à
l'amendement 3500 2 madame pensait Monge
et vous l'avez vu lorsque les sénateurs
veulent accélérer ils peuvent le faire
donc après cette le fait que le groupe
écologiste est renoncé à toutes ces
demandes de scrutin public sur cet
article 6 on a donc assisté et bien au
rejet de très nombreux amendements mais
noté toutefois et bien que deux
amendements ont été adoptés celui de la
de d'Élisabeth Doisneau qui est la
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales mais ne restez aussi
et bien un amendement qui a été adopté
de Elian assassin à la présidente du
groupe communiste d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure et bien Gabriel Attal a dit que
c'était le deuxième amendement de la
gauche auquel il donnait un avis
favorable depuis hier voilà comme quoi
et bien peut-être que les débats ne sont
pas si noir et blanc que ça enfin notez
il s'agit quand même seulement de deux
amendements voilà les discussions se
poursuivent mais on sent bien que le
rythme est s'accélère et que tout le
monde souhaite quand même en arriver à
ce fameux article 7 sur le report de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite de
62 à 64 ans dans les prochaines minutes
ne quittez pas nous sommes toujours là
sur Public Sénat nous suivons les débats
très attentivement la vie de la
commission sur le 4135 monsieur le
rapporteur
merci Monsieur le Ministre même avis je
mets aux voix donc avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient pas adopter l'amendement
de 1903 de même Lubin
madame Ferret
oui merci
merci Madame la
présidentectionnel qui vise à garantir
la clarté la sincérité des débats par
rapport à notre question des retraites
il existe bien malgré ce que le
gouvernement se plait à vouloir nous
faire croire une alternative à cette
réforme qui est rejetée par deux
Français sur trois 9 sur 10 parmi les
actifs quand le président de la
République on appelle au bon sens des
Français au moins il devrait les
entendre enfin ça a été dit plusieurs de
mes collègues les milliers de Français
sont dans la rue aujourd'hui et j'ai
oublié de préciser tout à l'heure en
évoquant au département et la ville de
Vire c'est la première l'ancien
conscription de la première ministre
peut-être que elle ne sera pas
insensible à ce qui se passe dans son
territoire
merci beaucoup la vie de la commission
favorable défavorable merci la vie du
gouvernement même avis je mets aux voix
donc l'amendement de 1903 avec un double
avis défavorable qui est pour qui contre
qui s'abstient pas adopté le 4137 a été
défendu la vie de la commission
défavorable
4137 avec défavorable qui est pour qui
est contre qui s'abstient pas adopté
même pensé mon choix
merci la vie de la Commission
merci Monsieur le Ministre ma fille
merci donc je mets au revoir maman 3500
avec deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient adopter le
4127 donc qui a été défendu la vie de la
Commission
merci
si je mets aux voix donc amendement qui
est pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
n'est pas adopté le 4173 qui a été
défendu à vide la commission défavorable
à vie du gouvernement pareil je mets aux
voix donc qui est pour qui est contre
qui ça tient pas adopter le 3478 m'a
même pensé Monge
merci la vie de la commission
défavorable merci je mets donc aux voix
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient pas adopté le 3479 madame
ponce
merci la Villa commission
monsieur le ministre donc de sa vie
défavorable qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté deux
amendements
identiques le 3213 même pensé mange
merci le deuxième a été défendu même
assassine la vie de la Commission sur
ces deux amendements je suppose
défavorable à commission merci Monsieur
le Ministre même avis merci donc je mets
aux voix cet amendement qui est pour qui
est contre qui s'abstient ils ne sont
pas adoptés le
3481 madame ponce
merci
mais ma vie monsieur le rapporteur même
la rapporteur défavorable mais voilà je
mets aux voix qui est pour cet
amendement qui est contre qui s'abstient
n'est pas adopté le 2905 de même Lubin
défendu avis de la commission
défavorable ce ministre je mets aux voix
qui est pour qui contre qui s'abstient
n'est pas adopté
4139 a été défendu la vie de la
commission est défavorable je suppose
monsieur le ministre également donc je
mets aux voix qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté
le 4164 qui a été défendu par Madame
assassy la ville de la commission les
favorable monsieur le ministre merci je
mets aux voix qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté
trois amendements sur l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 4153 qui a été
défendu le 3238 de même penser Monge
merci le 3487 m'a même pensé manger
également non
s'il vous plaît oui merci même ma
présidence si là j'aimerais prendre le
temps de défendre
la proposition d'un plan qui ouvre 500
000 de place de garde adaptée aux cinq
ans parce que je crois entendre dans
cette assemblée qu'on demande souvent
aux femmes de d'avoir plus d'enfants
et bien je suis désolé mais il y a un
phénomène que bien connu des démographes
qui s'appellent la transition
démographique
c'est la peine de vous dire qu'elle est
irréversible
elle dépend effectivement du niveau
d'éducation des filles des niveaux de la
protection sociale dont la retraite elle
défend aussi du fait que les femmes ou
pas travaillent enfin de beaucoup de
phénomènes et elle est irréversible
et
d'ailleurs je suis un peu étonné parce
qu'en général vous vous
comment vous conseiller la transition
démographique au pays africains mais
quand elle a lieu dans notre beau
continent bien blanc peut-être là il
faudrait qu'elle soit réversible alors
moi ce que je vous propose avec cet
amendement c'est de permettre aux femmes
qui veulent travailler de travailler
plutôt que de leur demander de faire des
enfants et quand elle le souhaite et du
coup de remédier par cet amendement et
bien d'autres
propositions au fait que plusieurs
points séparent le taux d'activité des
femmes parce que elles n'ont pas de
propositions de garde d'enfants etc ou
parce que
elles ont un temps partiel subi et donc
du coup si elles étaient à temps
complexes ça rapporterait des recettes à
notre protection sociale et je passe
quand même parce qu'on l'a beaucoup dit
on leur dira demain que l'égalité des
rémunérations entre les femmes et les
hommes apporteraient ces milliards donc
voilà
des places de crèche plutôt qu'une
injonction aux femmes
d'avoir plus de deux enfants en France
qui est à peu près la moyenne mais
beaucoup l'avis de la commission sur ces
trois amendements
défavorables sur les trois monsieur le
ministre défavorables donc je mets aux
voix l'amendement 4153 vider favorable
commission et gouvernement qui pour qui
est contre qui ça tient pas adopté le
3238 même avis même vote
le 3487 même avis même vote merci trois
amendements dont deux identiques le 3496
monsieur do su
merci madame la Présidente c'est un
amendement pour rappeler quelques
évidences se rappeler que si les
recettes se sont forcément contractées
c'est d'abord parce que le gouvernement
a exonéré massivement les entreprises
des cotisations sociales le besoin de
financement de la sécurité sociale et de
l'État est ainsi
entretenu par des dispositifs qui
privent la sécurité sociale et de
cotisations et l'état de nombreuses
recettes
les le coup des niches sociales est
évalué à 90 milliards d'euros par la
Cour des comptes soit 3,5 points du
produit intérieur brut certaines
exonérations sont particulièrement
pénalisantes pour le système de retraite
comme les exonérations sur les heures
supplémentaires qui ne sont pas
compensées par l'État leur suppression
rapporterait 2,3 milliards à la branche
vieillesse la suppression d'exonération
de cotisations inutiles rapporterait au
total 10 milliards d'euros en d'autres
termes en faisant travailler deux ans de
plus les Français vous leur faites payer
la facture de vos
errements dogmatiques je remercie
si donc le 4182 4166 ont été défendus
donc la vie de la commission favorable
merci Monsieur le Ministre défavorable
merci je mets donc aux voiles les deux
amendements
identiques 3496 4182 de double avis des
favorable qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient pas d'opté le 4166 même à
lui-même vote merci le 32008 même pensé
Monge
même la présidente mon amendement en
faveur des femmes n'ayant pas été votées
je vois que ça ne nous sert pas à grand
chose de défendre ici nos amendements
pour trouver des solutions pourtant au
problème des recettes de notre régime de
retraite donc
désormais pour le reste de l'article 6
considéré mes amendements comme défendus
alors donc la vie de la commission sur
le 32008 défavorable merci monsieur le
ministre des favorable donc je mets aux
voix cet amendement double avis
défavorable qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté donc le
4184 de même assassin défendue
avis de la commission
monsieur le ministre défavorable je mets
aux voix qui est pour qui est contre qui
ça tient n'est pas adopté le 4185 de
Madame assassy la vie de la commission
défavorable monsieur le ministre
défavorable je mets aux voix qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient je me
demandais un peu de silence quand même
merci trois amendements dont deux
identiques donc le
3498 de Madame poncemonge et le 4191 de
Madame assassy la Commission est
défavorables défavorables je vais mettre
aux voix donc qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstiente pas adopter et le
4192 de madame assassy qui est pour qui
est contre mais ma vie pas adoptée même
vote le 3183 donc de même pensément je
défavorable défavorables je mets donc
aux voix qui est pour qui est contre pas
adopté le 3211 même penser Monge
défavorable défavorables je mets aux
voix qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient n'est pas adopter le 3200
même voilà nous interrompons quelques
instants la discussion mais vous le
voyez à la discussion et bien les
sénateurs ont mis vraiment le pied sur
l'accélérateur puisque et bien il y a un
total changement de stratégie de la
gauche qui jusqu'ici avait bien
multiplié les prises de parole les
explications de vote sur les différents
amendements et là va très vite les
sénateurs n'explique même plus pour la
plupart et bien l'objet de leurs
amendements et les amendements sont
directement mis au vote car on le
comprend et bien l'objectif c'est bien
d'arriver à l'article 7 indices quelques
dizaines de minutes et là on va à
nouveau changer complètement de rythme
il y avait tout à l'heure 26 prises de
parole mais ça grossissait de minutes en
minutes presque 80 amendements de
suppression Steve il faut dire que
l'article 7 c'est ce que l'on attend
tous le report de l'âge légal de départ
la retraite de 62 à 64 ans oui on sent
comme un peu d'animation dans
l'hémicycle presque un frisson dans
l'hémicycle tout le monde se prépare
évidemment à examiner cette article 7 et
la question qu'on se pose nous
journaliste c'est bien de savoir si le
Sénat entendu le message de la rue le
message des mobilisations parisiennes et
comment ce message et bien va-t-il se
traduire dans l'hémicycle du Sénat on
verra ça dans quelques instants place en
tout cas à une séquence beaucoup plus
plus politique dans quelques instants
donc avec cet article 7 puisque le
l'hémistique va être très
schématiquement divisé en deux d'un côté
la droite de l'autre côté et bien la
gauche pourquoi en deux et bien parce
que le groupe macroniste ici le groupe
RDP au Sénat ne compte que 24 sénateurs
sur 300 48 tous les yeux seront donc
braqués vers la droite vers le groupe LR
notamment qui défend l'âge de le recul
de l'âge de départ à la retraite et
évidemment la gauche la gauche qui sera
en quelque sorte l'animateur de la
soirée qui va nous entraîner jusqu'au
bout de la nuit puisque la gauche a
déposée 1300 amendements c'est énorme
1300 amendements et sur ces 1300
amendements 77 amendements sont des
amendements de suppression des
amendements qui viennent dire non au
recul de l'âge de départ à la retraite
la gauche qui veut donc montrer qu'elle
s'effront avec la rue ici dans cette
hémicy contre la réforme des retraites
d'Emmanuel Macron et oui nous serons là
jusqu'au bout de la nuit un peu tête
vers trois quatre heures du matin merci
beaucoup Steve et on retrouve tout de
suite l'hémicycle ou Pascal Grigny la
vice-présidente du Sénat continue de
présider la séance
excusez-moi un article additionnel après
l'article 6 mais impensément je le 3226
là nous sommes à l'art il est défendu
merci
mais ma vie même vote
merci le 4000 pardon le 4415 de Madame
assassy même avis même vote
[Musique]
le 4410 de même assassin mais ma vie
même votre
le
4661 de Madame Vogel mais ma vie même
vote
le
4413 même assassis mamazie même vote
alors je vais mettre au voile l'ensemble
de la première partie du projet de loi
je rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 47 bis tirer un à alinéa 3 du
règlement lorsque le Sénat n'adopte pas
les dispositions de cette partie
l'ensemble du projet de loi est
considéré comme rejeté
y a-t-il des demandes d'explication de
voteaux
alors madame la Présidente c'est pas une
explication de vote c'est plutôt de de
faire un petit compte-rendu si je puis
dire de cette première partie qui
finalement
pardon
qui arrive en fait dans cette sixième
journée enfin à sa conclusion si je puis
dire puisque nous allons voter cette
première partie je voudrais
oui nous allons donc un petit peu résumé
les éléments que nous avons pu
voter pendant cette première partie déjà
une une loi qui comprenait un certain
nombre de sujets dans ces articles entre
l'article liminaire qui définissait
justement cet objectif de loi
paramétrique pour répondre
à la pérennité de notre système de
retraite par répartition et puis ce
premier article dans lequel nous avons
beaucoup parlé des régimes spéciaux
et puis cet article 2 qui nous a
beaucoup occupé parce que nous l'avons
toujours dit ici au Sénat l'importance
de cette loi elle réside dans le fait de
proposer pour les seniors et bien
l'activité qui est nécessaire en tout
cas dans notre société la place des
seniors est importante nous l'avons dit
un ensemble de dispositions ont été
proposées l'index senior je sais que
vous n'étiez pas tous emballés par ce
fameux index mais cependant je pense que
l'on responsabilise et on donne une
certaine transparence sur la politique
des entreprises en termes de maintien et
d'embauche des seniors et puis nous
avons ce fameux CDI qui a été défendu
par mon collègue René Paul Savary avec
beaucoup de brio et auquel nous sommes
vraiment très attachés on reçoit les uns
et les autres quelques petits courriers
nous indiquant combien c'est important
de savoir qu'il ex istera désormais cet
outil parce que même ont été
renvoyés de l'entreprise qu'ils n'ont
pas pu
continuer l'activité professionnelle
dans laquelle ils étaient trop tôt dans
leur dans leur vie et donc nous pensons
qu'il est important de maintenir ce CDI
monsieur le ministre monsieur les
ministres parce que c'est vraiment une
réponse
je dirais à la voix de garage
qu'aujourd'hui on a plutôt tendance à
proposer à nos seniors ensuite nous
avons revu les tableaux d'équilibre
l'objectif d'amortissement de la dette
sociale on y a passé aussi un petit peu
de temps et sur l'annexe A nous avons
depuis ce matin
balayer l'ensemble des sujets que nous
avions déjà évoqué hier avec ses
propositions de cotisations nouvelles
d'imposition nouvelle qui nous était
proposé plutôt par l'ensemble de ces
bancs ici et nous l'avons redit nous ne
voulons pas taxer le travail nous
voulons absolument que les entreprises
puissent justement avoir la même
opportunité de proposer de l'emploi et
que les productions ne soient pas
pénalisées par des cotisations
supplémentaires ni même par des impôts
c'était important de le dire et je pense
que pour les entreprises c'est un signe
aussi favorable pour la compétitivité de
notre monde économique
j'ai dépassé mon temps mais c'est la
première partie madame la Présidente et
je voulais en tout cas vous redire
combien ces débats ont été importants et
que nous allons poursuivre avec le cœur
de cette réforme paramétrique puisque
nous allons désormais parler de l'âge de
report de départ à la retraite et je
pense que nous y sommes aussi
nous sommes en tout cas très impatient
de débattre sur le cœur de cette réforme
merci de votre attention
je vais juste rappeler à mes collègues
que la rapporteur effectivement on
pourrait aussi lui donner un peu moins
de temps mais c'est quand même la
rapporteur pour la Commission et surtout
sur la première partie monsieur manteau
j'ai vous vouliez prendre la parole ah
bon d'accord bon alors j'étais saisie
d'une demande de scrutin public par la
commission des affaires sociales sur
l'ensemble de la première partie il va
être procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
voilà un demande de scrutin public sur
la première partie de ce projet de loi
de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale vous l'avez entendu à
Elizabeth Doisneau on a résumé les
grandes lignes et il s'agit bien de
l'extinction d'un certain nombre de
régimes spéciaux qui demeure avec la
clause du grand-père néanmoins régime
spéciaux de la RATP de la Banque de
France des gaziers des électriciens des
clercs de notaire il y a également et
bien dans cette première partie et bien
ce que ce qui avait été rejeté à
l'Assemblée nationale et qui a été
adoptée au Sénat le fameux index senior
index que les Sénats a préféré limiter
aux entreprises qui ont plus de 300
salariés notez que le Sénat il y a
assorti également un CDI un senior c'est
à dire un CDI sur lequel et bien les
entreprises n'auraient pas à de
cotisations famille voilà et notez
également que lors de cette première
partie les sénateurs ont rajouté et bien
le principe de la réflexion sur
l'introduction d'une part de
capitalisation collective dans notre
système aujourd'hui par répartition
voilà les sénateurs sont encore en train
de voter on écoute le vote
résultat du scrutin votant 344 exprimé
338 pour 236 contre 102 le Sénat a
adopté la première partie de ce texte et
je vais passer la parole à Monsieur le
Ministre
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente un mot
rapidement pour remercier les sénatrices
et les sénateurs pour remercier la
rapporteur général le rapporteur ça
varie la présidente de roche vous
remercie chacune et chacun d'entre vous
pour la qualité des débats que nous
avons eu nous avons des désaccords ils
sont nombreux avec certains bancs de
cette émission mais enfin je crois que
nous avons réussi à montrer que nous
étions capables de les exprimer d'une
manière respectueuse républicaine projet
contre projets et c'est évidemment moi
ce qui m'importe la discussion va
maintenant se poursuivre mais je le dis
à l'issue de l'adoption de cette
première partie c'est une étape majeure
dans cette réforme des retraites qui
vient d'être franchie avec le vote de
cette première partie c'est une étape
majeure puisque c'est le vote de la
première partie de ce texte ici au Sénat
une étape majeure aussi puisque
maintenant dans la suite de la
discussion la question est claire
voulez-vous voulons nous équilibrer ou
pas notre système de retraite à horizon
2030 pour permettre de payer les
pensions à bientôt 30 millions de
retraités ou pas si c'est le cas ça
passe par un recul de l'âge légal de
départ puisqu'à l'issue de cette
première partie votre assemblée a refusé
les augmentations d'impôts nombreuses
qui étaient proposées notamment sur les
bancs gauche de cette émission et donc
c'est une étape très importante pour ce
point merci merci alors nous allons
passer à la deuxième partie
alors je suis saisie tout d'abord de
d'un amendement 3680 de Madame ponce sur
les suppressions de l'intitulé
défendu alors la vie de la Commission
monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable la vie du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
monsieur mise des favorable merci je
mets aux voix donc l'amendement 3180
double avis défavorable qui est pour qui
est contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté le
3395 madame poncemonge des défendu sur
les deux prochains il est défendu
d'accord la commission défavorable
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement
défavorable je mets aux voix cet
amendement double avis défavorable qui
est pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
pas adopté alors ensuite
deux amendements
alors le premier de Madame Pontier Monge
donc il est défendu madame Fonty Dossa
pour le 2312
oui merci madame la Présidente
nous sommes avec Gabriel Attal ministre
de l'action et des comptes publics merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous d'abord un mot
sur la tonalité des débats au Sénat vous
venez de remercier les sénateurs est-ce
que vous avez trouvé ça différent de
l'Assemblée oui on a eu de vrais débats
de fond un projet contre projet avec
notamment les bons de la gauche qui
proposait des augmentations d'impôts de
cotisations là où effectivement nous
proposons d'équilibrer notre système en
passant par un recul de l'âge légal de
départ ça s'est fait toujours dans un
cadre respectueux républicain c'est ce
que j'ai voulu saluer pas vraiment
d'obstruction alors pour vous de la part
de la gauche il y a eu quelques
longueurs mais on a vu qu'à certains
moments aussi ça accélérait encore une
fois l'important c'est qu'on puisse
parler de tous les sujets alors est-ce
que vous souhaitez quand même du coup
vraiment accélérer sur les débats pour
la suite on le sait il y a des outils à
la main du gouvernement à la main de la
majorité sénatoriale pour non mais ce
qu'il faut c'est que on puisse continuer
à examiner ce texte les différents
sujets il y a beaucoup de sujets qui
arrivent évidemment le recul de l'âge
légal de départ à 64 ans mais il y a
aussi des articles sur l'extension de la
retraite progress arrive à la fonction
publique sur la question des carrières
longues il faut qu'on puisse examiner
tous ces sujets j'ai pas de doute qu'on
parviendra à le faire alors est-ce que
l'équilibre financier de la réforme va
être assurée Gabriel Attal on a Olivier
du soft qui a dit dans une interview que
300 millions d'euros pourraient manquer
en 2030 et puis on voit un peu la note
qui s'alourdit le coup du CDI senior qui
a été adopté au Sénat le coup de la
surcote pour les maires de famille ayant
toutes leurs années à 63 ans la note va
s'alourdir ah mais l'équilibre de notre
système de retraite à horizon 2030 c'est
un objectif dont nous ne dérangerons pas
mais parce qu'il y a quoi derrière
l'équilibre il y a tout simplement le
fait d'être capable de continuer à payer
les pensions de nos retraités il y avait
12 millions de retraités dont il fallait
payer la pension au début des années
2000 on sera à 20 millions dans quelques
années c'est un doublement sur une
génération et donc la réalité c'est que
vous êtes obligé dans ces conditions de
prendre des mesures pour équilibrer le
système sinon ça veut dire qu'on devrait
baisser les pensions et on le refuse
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire que j'étais
défavorable au CDI seniors en tout cas
dans la manière dont réalité dont il a
été adopté par les sénateurs puisque ça
coûte très cher et je doute de
l'efficacité mais c'est des discussions
qui se poursuivront dans la navette
parlementaire et en commission mixte
paritaire certainement est-ce que vous
reconnaissez quand même des erreurs de
communication dans la façon dont le
gouvernement a géré cette réforme bien
sûr on pense tous au slogan sur les 1200
euros depuis on a compris que c'était
beaucoup plus compliqué que cela et
notamment Isabelle borne a été beaucoup
plus clair et plus complexe ces derniers
jours d'abord une réforme des retraites
c'est toujours difficile moi j'ai pas
d'exemple de réforme des retraites
demandant un effort aux Français qui
était particulièrement populaire quand
vous regardez en arrière c'est toujours
difficile c'est une réforme qui est
assez technique et on peut toujours
considérer qu'on aurait pu faire mieux
mais je pense que l'essentiel c'est en
permanence de chercher à expliquer à
être au contact moi je les fais mais en
termes de communication on peut toujours
évidemment moi je cherche toujours à
être au contact des français via les
médias évidemment mais aussi dans des
réunions publiques que j'ai multiplié
partout en France partout sur le
territoire pour aller au contact des
Français et chercher expliquer nos
intentions est-ce que vous considérez
que la droite sénatoriale comme votre
allié sur ce texte et au-delà désormais
mais vous savez en fait moi j'ai jamais
demandé à la droite sénatoriale ou LR de
l'assemblée de se rallier à nos
convictions tout simplement d'être mais
tout simplement d'être fidèle au leurre
en votant pour ce texte ils sont fidèles
à leurs conditions et à ce qu'ils ont
toujours porté en tout cas depuis des
années ici au Sénat merci merci beaucoup
Gabriel d'avoir répondu à mes questions
on va tout de suite rejoindre
l'hémicycle là l'article 7 doit être en
train de commencer tout de suite en
rejoint les mystiques de l'article 7
cette notion porte le numéro 4750 et la
parole est à Madame A poursu poli pour
la motion et pour deux minutes
comme vous voulez chers collègues
vous avez deux minutes
merci madame la Présidente nous y sommes
au cœur de votre projet de loi déclaré
ircevable par notre peuple la
mobilisation est massive la levée
populaire rappelle les grandes heures de
l'histoire sociale de notre pays
monsieur le ministre il vous reste la
légalité institutionnelle mais vous avez
perdu la légitimité sociale nous ne
pourrons plus poursuivre le débat de la
même manière qu'hier votre texte est
massivement rejeté nous le savions tous
depuis le 19 janvier date de la première
journée de manifestation et de grève nos
concitoyens et concitoyens n'ont pas
lâché ils sont aujourd'hui plus nombreux
encore dans l'action c'est un
raz-de-marée contre la réforme
profondément injuste de Monsieur Macron
et de son gouvernement nous l'avons dit
répéter comment avez-vous osé provoquer
le pays ainsi s'il y a blocage si nous
sommes dans cette situation de crise
sociale majeure monsieur le ministre aux
côtés le contrôle du président de la
République et de la première ministre
vous emportez l'unique responsabilité
votre obsession libérale votre pensée
dogmatique vous ont poussé à la faute
vous êtes tombé dans votre propre piège
dont vous aurez bien du mal à vous
sortir vous n'avez plus expliqué au
travailleur qu'il soit salarié ou non
pourquoi ils devront s'user à la tâche
plus longtemps porter l'âge légal du
départ à la retraite à 64 ans n'a pu
passer car tous ont bien compris que
notre moyen existent pour financer le
régime des retraites par répartition
d'autres solutions dont vous n'avez pas
parlé à commencer par mettre à
contribution les richesses considérables
de la grande puissance que nous sommes
main dans la main le président de la
République et la majorité sénatoriale
dans l'affichage enfin de cette union
des droites veulent imposer la
destruction d'un pilier de notre
République la sécurité sociale écoutons
le peuple écoutons pour une fois le
peuple soutenez mes chers collègues
notre demande refuser l'âge de départ à
64 ans merci chers collègues alors
maladie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente mais
c'est strictement interdit jour à peine
mes collègues un peu de respect quand
même pour l'assistance s'il vous plaît
vous voulez peut-être toujours fait moi
je vous dis c'est interdit madame la
Présidente assassin j'en suis désolé
voilà la parole est à monsieur le
rapporteur non on n'est pas la parole
même la présidente pour l'instant non
même la présidence je vais donner la
parole à Monsieur le rapporteur de
parole je suis en cours de paroles je
viens parce que c'est un monsieur
monsieur le rapporteur merci Madame
Liliana Sassi bon effet tribune étant
passé on va revenir à la sérénité des
débats
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes sereins nous aussi parce que
nous pensons que véritablement si
nous proposons une réforme dont on sait
qu'elle peut être difficile à accepter
pour certains
c'est pour faire que nous puissions
maintenir notre système de répartition à
l'équilibre et quand on sait que nous
avons de moins en moins de cotisants et
des retraites qui durent de plus en plus
longtemps si nous le prenons pas nos
responsabilités ce sont les générations
futures qui paieront la note et qui la
paieront beaucoup plus cher il nous
appartient et vous le savez
2 poursuivre le débat nos concitoyens
l'attentes se débat en ce qui concerne
effectivement ces inégalités ces
inégalités qu'il y a dans la vie
professionnelle ces inégalités qui se
déclinent également dans le système de
retraite et nos concitoyens sont
impatients ils nous l'ont dit que leur
en propose que leur propose
qu'on leur propose des mesures qui
prennent en compte ces inégalités
qui prennent en compte l'usure
professionnelle qui prennent en compte
les mers de famille ça fait déjà plus de
3 jours que nous siègeons où nous avons
entendu nombre de discours tout à fait
justifié et il nous appartient
maintenant de passer à l'acte c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous donnons un
avis défavorable pour retourner en
commission faire le travail que nous
avons déjà largement fait merci la vie
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente je crois que
la discussion sur la première partie a
montré que le sujet s'il est complexe
est aussi un sujet qui peut être clivant
et qui a l'occasion de cette discussion
en première partie sur les différents
articles financiers sur les déclarations
générales ces questions relatives à
l'âge au choix que nous avons fait
évidemment et il faut le dire demander
un effort aux Français avec un peu plus
de travail faire progressivement certes
certes de manière plus aussi adaptée
possible aussi justement réparti que
possible peut faire débats ce que nous
ce cheval que nous avons fait nous l'ont
fait pour deux raisons parce que c'est
celui qui permet d'une part de ramener
le système à l'équilibre et d'autre part
de financer à la fois les mesures
d'accompagnement et les droits nouveaux
que nous créons avec cette réforme je
crois que les travaux en commission les
travaux à l'occasion de la première
partie ont déjà largement éclairé le
débat et qu'il n'y a pas lieu de
retarder ce débat sur l'article 7 donc
la vie est favorable
merci beaucoup alors y a-t-il des
explications de vote un représentant par
groupe même
merci madame la Présidente cet article
est effectivement au coeur de la réforme
la mobilisation considérable à laquelle
nous assistons aujourd'hui la grève
puissante qui a été lancée dans le
secteur public comme dans le secteur
privé à un objectif clair et précis le
retrait de ce projet détestable qui
institut le recul de l'âge de départ à
la retraite mais aussi de tout
l'habillage l'accompagnant relevant bien
souvent de la manipulation même du
mensonge comme ce plancher à 2000 à 1200
euros pardon destiné d'abord à
l'ensemble des retraités à venir et
actuels pour finalement être réservé à
10000 au mieux 20 000 personnes cette
mobilisation marque aussi un ras-le-bol
bien plus profond une colère rentrée
cette colère elle s'exprime comme contre
ces sociétés injustes marquées par la
précarité précarité dans le travail le
logement l'accès aux soins le
déroulement des études l'accès aux
services publics nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyens n'en plus de toutes ces
inégalités qui s'accroisent dans notre
pays avec un étalage indécent de
richesse un affichage de profits
dantesques accumulés y compris sur le
dos des cris sanitaires énergie
énergétique sur la sur la guerre c'est
profiteur de crise les maîtres de la
finance ceux qui tiennent la
l'actionnariat ont poussé à une telle
réforme ce sont eux qui ont tenu la main
de Monsieur Macron pour écrire ce nouvel
asservissement que décrète ce projet de
loi les femmes et les hommes de ce pays
le voient le savent elle est le cri ils
ont soif de justice d'égalité la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat comme le Parlement tout entier
doit travailler dans la précipitation
extrême décidée par le seul gouvernement
la voie choisie de l'article 47 1 permet
d'aller vite mais ça n'est pas
démocratique ce n'est pas le bon vecteur
législatif il est temps maintenant
madame la Présidente de nous réunir à
nouveau pour prendre en compte ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui une très grande
colère et un rejet massif de cette
réforme scélérate mais si même la
présidente rossignol
merci Madame la pardon merci madame la
Présidente il y a un instant le
rapporteur nous disait ça fait trois
jours que nous sions nous pouvons donc
continuer il n'y a pas de raison de
retourner en commission ça fait trois
jours que nous sions et que nous parlons
de gens qui travaillent depuis plus de
40 ans qui eux attendent la retraite qui
prennent le train tous les matins c'est
se demander partement pour beaucoup
d'entre eux qui tous les jours compte
parce que vous n'y pensez pas vous n'y
pensez pas aux gens qui ont un
calendrier et qui cochent les jours
parce que après une vie de travail après
une vie de souffrance après une vie de
fatigue ils attendent de la retraite
parce que c'est le moment ils pourront
enfin s'occuper de leur petit enfant
avoir des loisirs et puis surtout se
reposer alors franchement entre des gens
qui travaillent depuis plus de 40 ans et
qu'attendent la retraite et nous qui
travaillons depuis trois jours retourner
en commission on a le temps on peut le
faire et puis et par ailleurs retournez
en commission pourquoi faire c'est la
question qu'on peut se poser en bon
membre de la commission des affaires
sociales que nous sommes les uns et les
autres mais je vous proposais déjà un
ordre du jour pour le retour en
commission recevoir l'Inter syndical
nous ne l'avons jamais fait en
commission en tant que tel
et puis peut-être que ça donnera des
idées au gouvernement et au ministre et
à la première ministre qui pourront eux
aussi pendant que nous serons en
commission à rediscuter de cet article 7
recevoir l'intersyndical ils ne le sont
jamais perçus
alors je vous suggère effectivement de
faire comme mon groupe de voter cette
motion de renvoi en commission pour
examiner article 7
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
gonta
oui merci Madame merci madame la
Présidente de la même manière évidemment
que tout ce qu'il y a de soutiendrons ce
renvoie en commission d'abord quand même
une remarque parce que c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois qu'on met des visages
derrière cette réforme à chaque fois
qu'on parle des gens à chaque fois qu'on
met des prénoms à chaque fois qu'on cite
des professions ça vous gêne on entend
et je pense que c'est particulièrement
oui mais ça pose quand même question
parce que c'est quand même ce qu'on est
en train de faire on est en train de
changer de la vie de gens justement
derrière leur prénom derrière le métier
et de leur dire que vous allez
travailler un an deux ans de plus c'est
une réalité et un moment va falloir
aussi l'assumer parce que c'est pas que
des chiffres c'est pas que des textes
derrière il y a des personnes donc ça je
pense que c'est aussi important que vous
l'ayez en tête ensuite se renvoi en
commission et le fait peut-être d'avoir
un peu plus de temps pour que
effectivement je vois que le ministre
ont besoin de discuter ont besoin de
parler donc je pense qu'on a peut-être
besoin de se renvoi en commission merci
Monsieur le merci monsieur le ministre
et puis
également j'ai lu j'ai entendu un peu
près j'ai vu dans certains articles en
tout cas il y a des bruits qui courent
qui auraient des réunions en tout cas
qu'on commencerait à discuter de la
future de la future CMP qu'on sera en
train de se mettre d'accord parce que
d'ailleurs monsieur le rapporteur n'est
plus le rapporteur de la commission
parce que il dit nous il est le
rapporteur du groupe du groupe LR il est
le rapporteur de ce texte et le
rapporteur du gouvernement donc très
bien je veux dire vous êtes en train de
faire un texte entre vous c'est très
bien donc je pense qu'il y a peut-être
ce temps là mais nous on a peut-être
aussi du temps pour avancer pour vous
faire des propositions on a essayé d'en
faire depuis trois jours je pense qu'on
va encore en faire et on a encore du
temps devant nous et on va pas se priver
de vous faire des propositions parce que
effectivement ce texte est
particulièrement injuste et je pense que
les manifestations ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui sans précédent dans notre
pays un moment il va falloir peut-être
l'entendre parce que non on ne gouverne
pas contre le peuple
merci Monsieur mouillé
merci Madame présidente mes chers
collègues je nous comprenons tout à fait
que nous sommes là à la veille quelques
minutes de l'examen de l'article 7 et
que vu la situation de la journée vous
soyez motivé remonté pour porter vos
valeurs et donc votre vision on le
comprend tout à fait mais toutefois
comme ça a été très bien dit par
rapporteur rappelons que nous sommes
cohérents dans nos démarches et que le
début de l'examen de ce texte nous
savons que la techno 7 et l'article
fondamentale pour équilibrer notre futur
système de retraite à l'aube de 2030
c'était essentiel nous le savons et vous
devezvoquer souvent des visages des
rencontres des personnes souffrantes que
vous rencontrez mais nous également
lorsqu'on rencontre un certain nombre de
couple et que on évoque avec eux
l'avenir de leur retraite souvent nous
disent on n'aura pas de retraite les
plus jeunes j'ai dit on n'aura pas de
retraite non pas parce que vous évoquez
vos arguments c'est parce qu'ils savent
pertinemment que si on met pas en place
une réforme courageuse avec des vraies
valeurs nous serons incapables de
financer un niveau digne de retraite et
donc c'est l'outil que nous proposons
aujourd'hui
donc on a aussi ce regard vis-à-vis de
nos concitoyens et puis pour ceux qui
évoquent le fait de d'avoir plus de
temps en commission la terre ça dit
qu'elle a été reçu au commission il
fallait peut-être présent que les choses
à ce moment-là et puis depuis 4 ans nous
avons le même discours nous travaillons
nous avons reçu un Salton d'acteurs dans
cette mission donc il y a rien de
nouveau nous sommes nous sommes prêts
les sales rencontrés ont été vus
simplement un moment donné relisez les
contrôles de commission et on gagne du
temps ce soir merci
alors
j'ai pris la parole pour rappeler en
effet que le 15 février nous avons passé
la matinée à recevoir les organisations
syndicales les organisations patronales
et que les rapporteurs les que je ne
sais pas si vous êtes intervenu
l'ancien madame madame Rossignol on
regardera je n'en ai pas vraiment le
souvenir mais pourquoi pas oui pourquoi
pas mais enfin ça c'est un détail les
rapporteurs depuis
des années que nous faisons des
amendements pfss reçoivent les
organisations syndicales certes ne sont
pas d'accord avec la proposition qu'on
fait mais néanmoins nous les recevons et
puis moi je vais vous dire j'en ai un
peu marre de ces propos ici disons mais
qu'est-ce que vous connaissez du travail
qu'est-ce que vous connaissez de la vie
qu'est-ce que vous savez vous de nos
origines qu'est-ce que vous savez de
nous nos vies
rien
bonne journée un petit peu marre
qu'est-ce que vous savez de nos vies
qu'est-ce que vous savez de nos familles
qu'est-ce que vous savez ce qu'on a vécu
ou ce que nos parents ont vécu rien
alors vous arrêtez avec ça
merci
alors je vais consulter le Sénat sur la
motion de renvoi à la commission de la
fête la vie du gouvernement et de la
commission sont défavorables qui est
pour
cette notion
qui est contre qui s'obtient n'est pas
adopté
alors à l'article 7 je les demande de
prise de parole et le premier monsieur
le rapporteur Savary
non c'est pas possible oui merci madame
la Présidente nous y voilà nous y voilà
c'est le Ministre ça fait quatre ans
qu'on vous propose ce type
d'acheitecture de réforme c'est pas
parce que nous sommes des têtus c'est
parce que nous pensons que c'est le
meilleur moyen de faire en sorte de
pouvoir équilibrer notre système de
retraite si nous voulons le confier à
nos enfants et effectivement on sait que
nous avons un système fondé sur deux
piliers à la fois la durée de cotisation
et un autre pilier un âge légal la durée
de cotisation qui a été ramenée de 41
ans et demi à 43 ans par un gouvernement
que vous avez largement soutenu et on
vous en remercie parce que c'est tout à
fait important mais on sait que cette
durée de cotisations quand on l'augmente
elle concerne davantage ceux qui
commencent tôt mais elle a un défaut
c'est que le niveau de pension moyenne
va diminuer derrière
c'est l'équation qui est ainsi faite
dans le calcul des pensions de carrière
et puis il y a un deuxième vecteur c'est
l'âge légal on sait que l'âge légal
touche plus spécifiquement et fait pour
ça pour faire en sorte que l'on puisse
protéger ceux qui commencent à
travailler tard et il a l'avantage c'est
d'augmenter le niveau des pensions et
nous avons pensé déjà depuis quatre ans
qu'il était important de trouver un
équilibre entre les deux de façon à ce
que quand on demande un effort collectif
à l'ensemble des Français il y ait le
moins d'inégalité possible c'est la
raison pour laquelle ces inégalités nous
souhaitons les gommer parce que elles
sont réelles et en conséquence monsieur
le ministre si vous nous avez rejoint
dans la démarche
vous n'avez pas été tout à fait jusqu'au
bout il reste encore un bout de chemin à
faire parce que si nous avions présenté
nous cette réforme nous l'aurions pas
fait de cette façon nous aurions déjà
consulté
nous aurions déjà consulter les
partenaires sociaux avant et nous
aurions pris en compte les difficultés
rencontrées dans le cadre de cet effort
collectif c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous allons débattre et que je ne suis
pas sûr que 57 amendements de
suppression tous ceux identique face
correctement avancer le débat merci
monsieur le rapporteur alors pour les
prises de parole madame la Présidente
Éliane assassy oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
lors de la présentation du projet de loi
la première ministre a placé son projet
sous le signe de je cite la préservation
d'un système menacé menacé par
l'accumulation des déficits qui seraient
irresponsable ce sont ces mots le
gouvernement justifie l'allongement de
l'âge légal à 64 ans et de la durée de
cotisation à 43 annuités par le déficit
de système de retraite pour 2030 à 13,5
milliard d'euros je rappelle quand même
qu'en 2019 lors de la précédente réforme
le gouvernement invoquait déjà
l'impérieuse nécessité de réformer le
système de retraite face au risque d'un
déficit du régime de 10 milliards
d'euros en 2022 la réforme fut
abandonnée sans réforme le système de
retraite a été excédentaire de 3,7
milliards d'euros alors on peut
s'interroger sur votre entêtement
monsieur le ministre de bien de vouloir
imposer deux années de travail
supplémentaire à nos concitoyens et si
je ne connais pas la vie de chaque
parlementaire ici présent je connais
celle de centaines de s'écano Dionysiens
parmi lesquels celles et ceux que nous
avons applaudis pendant l'épidé
l'épidémie et qui refuse aujourd'hui
qu'on leur vole deux années de leur vie
les 8 syndicats de salariés sont unis
dans l'intercyndicale ils ont organisé
cinq journées de mobilisation qui ont
rassemblé énormément de monde je
rappelle que le 19 janvier il y avait
manifestants le 31 janvier 2,8 le 7 2
millions le 11 2,5 millions le 16 1,3
millions et c'était pendant les vacances
scolaires aujourd'hui et nous y est on
présente je me félicite d'un mouvement
social d'ampleur et rassembleur ce sont
plus de 3,5 millions de manifestants
parmi lesquels des milliers de jeunes
qui ont défilé aujourd'hui autour d'un
mot d'ordre retrait de votre réforme
monsieur le ministre votre obstination
met en danger notre société et vous vous
obstinez avec la complicité de la
majorité sénatoriale alors je vous le
dis sincèrement retirer ce projet de loi
pendant qu'il est encore temps merci
même Katy a pour ce poli
merci madame la
Présidente excusez-moi Xavier Bertrand
demandait je cite à la fin de cette
décennie il faudra que l'on arrive à
deux années de travail en plus en
excluant ceux qui ont son usé par le
boulot pour Valérie Pécresse je cite
reculer à 65 ans avec des contreparties
pour les longs les carrières longues et
sur la pénibilité Michel Barnier
défendait quant à lui une pension
minimale à 1000 euros philippe Juvin
était le seul candidat qui demandait la
mise en oeuvre d'une capitalisation
collective complémentaire en décembre
2022 pour l'élection du président du
parti des républicains notre collègue
s'est amateur le candidat Bruno
Retailleau défendait la fermeture des
régimes spéciaux l'allongement à 64 ans
et 43 annuités comme le gouvernement
tandis que le député Aurélien pradji
s'opposé à l'âge à l'allongement de
l'âge légal le candidat élu depuis
président des républicains érectionti
défendait lui le report en 2027 l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 65 ans
et à 63 ans pour les carrières longues
cette réforme des retraites ne
correspond donc ni au projet d'Aurélien
Pradier ni d'érections ni de Xavier
Bertrand ni de Philippe Juvin mais
uniquement à celle portée par le
président du groupe les républicains
monsieur retaillod
alors alors chers collègues en adorant
que vous vous mettez d'accord évidemment
pas ici parce qu'ici c'est quand même un
pour tous pour un et bien je vous
propose de retirer votre projet de
retraite néfaste pour les Français et
les Françaises je vous remercie merci
même Laurence Cohen vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente le
gouvernement justifie le report de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite comme une
réforme de justice et de progrès ce même
gouvernement se félicite d'acter l'âge
de 64 ans au lieu de 65 ans comme s'il
travaillait deux années de plus ne
représentait rien non seulement la
potion est amère mais elle est indigeste
monsieur le ministre les femmes vont
souffrir de cette réforme et le report
de l'âge légal défendu par se présente
article aura de lourds conséquences sur
elle et leur quotidien même si c'est
l'ensemble des Français qui vont
souffrir les femmes subissent déjà de
nombreuses inégalités lors de la
recherche d'emploi sur les salaires sur
les conséquences des crises sur leur
représentation dans les métiers pénibles
et non valorisés la réforme ne réduira
pas ses inégalités au contraire elle les
creusera à chaque fois qu'on repousse la
durée de cotisation on la rend toujours
moins atteignable pour les femmes si les
salaires des femmes sont inférieurs en
moyenne de 22% de ceux des hommes leurs
pensions de droit est inférieure de 40%
à celle des hommes alors s'il vous plaît
monsieur le ministre assumez vos
positions arrêtez ces mensonges qui
laissent sous-entendre que cette réforme
est favorable aux femmes elle subissent
depuis des décennies des réformes
injustes et cette réforme ajoute une
pièce à la machine et confirme le modèle
de société antisociale que vous défendez
vous voulez renflouer les caisses faites
respecter la loi en matière d'égalité
salariale on voulait déjà on vous l'a
déjà dit 6 milliards supplémentaires de
cotisations sociales non seulement cette
égalité dans la vie active permettrait
mécaniquement d'augmenter le niveau de
pension des femmes mais en plus cela
permettrait de revaloriser de façon bien
plus importante que ce que vous faites
les prestations sociales et les
retraites alors ne cherchez pas de faux
arguments de faux prétextes pour
justifier cette réforme retirez-la
écoutez la voix de la rue
mais si la parole est à Monsieur Thierry
Cosic
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'un de nos illustre prédécesseur le
président Mitterrand nous avait prévenu
après moi
il n'y aura que des comptables
et à l'examen de cet article monsieur le
ministre comment lui donner tort cet
article 7 vient toucher au coeur le
projet que vous portez et il ne trahit
que trop bien l'idéologie qui vous anime
en la matière
tout d'abord permettez-moi de vous dire
que cet article me paraît quasi
anachronique tant il fait fi des
bouleversements qui traversent notre
société depuis quelques années et
auxquels le gouvernement semble fermer
et pourtant la forte mobilisation
d'aujourd'hui en témoigne nous vivons
une période de changement sociétaux
gigantesque avec un nouveau rapport au
travail qui est en mutation et une
déstabilisation liée à la crise
sanitaire qui laisse encore des traces
aujourd'hui
l'ignorer c'est aller dans le mur
pour schématiser il y a trois grands
paramètres sur lesquels jouer pour
réformer notre système de retraite l'âge
de départ la durée et le niveau de
cotisation
des trois il n'y en a qu'un seul qui
touche les salariés de manière inégale
c'est la mesure d'âge car vous le savez
elle ne prend pas en considération la
date d'entrée sur le marché du travail
de fait en repoussant comme vous le
faites là je les gale vous envoyez une
facture
différente à nos concitoyens selon le
moment auquel ils auront commencé à
travailler et une fois n'est pas coutume
la facture la plus lourde elle est pour
ceux qu'on a appelé les travailleurs de
la deuxième ligne pendant la pandémie
les hôtes et hôtesses de caisses les
éboueurs les agents d'entretien ou les
aides à domicile qui sont aussi les
grands perdants de la mondialisation et
de la numérisation de l'économie voilà
comment vous remercier Monsieur le
Ministre toute cette frange de salariés
dont on a mesuré l'importance pendant la
crise sanitaire et qui ont commencé à
travailler jeune et on les métiers les
plus les plus pénibles
car
Lotti vous le voyez sur cet article 7
les sénateurs de la gauche multiplient
les prises de parole 26 prises de parole
qui sont prévus avant et bien d'examiner
le cœur de la réforme c'est à dire cet
article qui prévoit le report de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite de 62 à 64
ans c'est maintenant marièrent Carlotti
un sénatrice socialiste qui s'exprime
parce
qu'elle était à travers le report de
l'âge de départ à 64 ans vous faites
supporter la la totalité des efforts sur
les seuls travailleurs les classes
moyennes les plus vulnérables ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler tôt qui ont
exercé des métiers difficiles ceux qui
ont du mal à se maintenir en emploi
après 58 ans les femmes les personnes
précaires au chômage en maladie au RSA
alors qu'aucune aucune contribution
n'est demandée aux employeurs aux
revenus aux actionnaires non monsieur le
ministre votre réforme n'est pas de
gauche elle va à l'encontre de nos
valeurs de notre récit collective
souveniez en vous souvenez-vous de ça
vous avez présenté un bilan comptable
alors que nous ici nous vous parlons
d'un projet de société et jusqu'ici au
débats ont été des dialogues de sourds
sauf que depuis aujourd'hui les rapports
de force sont claire la colère des
Français vous oblige elle vous oblige à
prendre une ultime décision soit vous
renoncez à fracturer le pays à mettre
les Français dans la rue vous retirez
votre réforme et ouvrez des négociations
collectives avec les partenaires sociaux
soit vous vous obstinez à vouloir passer
en force et je crains qu'à ce moment là
vous devriez avoir au pire désormais le
président de la République ne peut plus
se défiler il faut qu'il parle aux
Français qui ne les poussent plus à bout
qui ne les respecte et qu'en frein enfin
vous et lui vous preniez acte du rejet
de cette réforme
merci la parole est à monsieur le
Président Pierre Laurent
la question qui nous occupe à cette
heure est une question
démocratique majeure après l'échec de
cette réforme à l'Assemblée nationale
une majorité du Sénat va-t-elle décider
de permettre le coup de force qui a été
qui est tenté par le gouvernement contre
les deux plus belles années de rotin des
Français un coup de force contre
l'immense majorité du pays un coup de
force contre tous les syndicats un coup
de force contre l'avenir du régime de
retraite par répartition nous débattons
ici depuis le 2 mars ça a été dit tout à
l'heure par Madame la rapporteur depuis
6 jours les Français nous écoutent les
Français nous suivent ils ont entendu
tous les arguments les vôtres les nôtres
ceux du rapporteur ceux du gouvernement
ils ont manifesté aujourd'hui en
connaissance de cause et le pays a
répondu clairement que pour lui c'était
et il a dit non dans toutes les villes
de France dans tous les départements
dans toutes nos régions tous nos
électeurs étaient dans la rue quand je
dis tous nos électeurs c'est les nôtres
c'est les vôtres aussi tous étaient dans
la rue pour dire NON de toute catégorie
sociale et j'attire votre attention
parce que c'est un fait majeur de la
journée d'aujourd'hui l'entrée en lice
massive de la jeunesse de la jeunesse
dans les manifestations et cela m'a
simplifié
nous avons vérifié pendant cette
discussion ce que les syndicats ont
vérifié pendant trois mois en essayant
de négocier avec le gouvernement le
gouvernement et la droite ne veulent
rien négocier vous êtes obsédé par une
seule idée les 64 ans à part ça rien ne
vous intéresse aucune piste alternative
de trouve grâce à vos yeux et bien je le
répète face au pays qui est unanimement
mobilisé c'est un coup de force ne
donnez pas la main à ce coup de force
sénateur et sénatrice du Sénat nous
n'avons pas à le faire
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre
une minorité peut pas bloquer le pays
aujourd'hui vous êtes seul plus personne
ne croit en votre projet mise à part
peut-être encore la droite sénatoriale
dont je tiens à les féliciter pour leur
talent même sans parler vous avez réussi
à empirer le texte avec le contrat
dernier embauche ou en introduisant une
part de capitalisation aujourd'hui
massivement les travailleurs et
travailleuses vous ont répondu ils ont
déferlé dans toutes les rues à Paris
comme en province dans toutes les
sous-préfectures et les villages pour
vous dire non non ils ne veulent pas
qu'on leur vole les deux plus belles
années de leur vie à la retraite chez le
ministre arrêté cette guerre sociale aux
travailleurs et travailleurs essentiels
et utiles aux salariés du privé comme du
public au premier deuxième et troisième
ligne au commerce artisan professionnel
et le chef d'entreprise aux jeunes et
retraités tout le monde est uni pour
vous dire STOP il n'y a qu'une seule
option maintenant qui est sur la table
c'est celle du retrait de votre projet
de loi personne ne veut cela et en plus
tous vos arguments sont tombés un par un
parce que nous vous avons fait pendant 5
jours beaucoup de propositions
alternatives des propositions de
financement taxer le capital faire
l'égalité salariale mettre un million de
personnes en emploi ce sont des
ressources supplémentaires et vous les
refusez parce que vous n'avez comme la
dit Pierre Laurent qu'une seule
obsession faire payer au million de
travailleurs et travailleuses la crise
est donc les faire travailler chacune et
chacun deux ans pour tous et donc nous
nous continuerons à un pied à pied
déterminé utile pour faire échec à ce
projet jusqu'au retrait
merci la parole est à Monsieur Pascal
voilà les sénateurs continuent à
multiplier les prises de parole sur cet
article 7 sur le report de l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite à 64 ans merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis merci
beaucoup à Steve Jourdain de nous avoir
accompagné tout au long de cette
émission vous allez pouvoir suivre la
suite des débats à partir de 22h sur
Public Sénat avec Mathias Arès et
Quentin Calmet qui sera à ma place donc
à 22h ne manquez pas la suite des débats
sur l'article 7 vous aurez encore un
nombre de prises de paroles vous aurez
aussi et bien les amendements de
suppression et puis toutes les
discussions qui s'annoncent
passionnantes autour de cet article
névralgique de cette réforme des
retraites l'article 7 qui porte donc sur
le report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans ne manquez pas non
plus toutes nos explications sur notre
site public sénat.fr très bonne suite
des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]
pour pouvoir produire de la neige de
culture sur 50% de pistes en plus on a
besoin de 50% plus en eau je pense qu'il
faut continuer dans l'enneigement mais
de façon raisonnée j'ai pris position
par rapport à un projet de retenue
colinéaire sur le territoire de La
Clusaz très clairement on me dit on va
s'occuper de toi on a investi dans le
ski dans des commerces donc c'est des
crédits en face c'est des loyers en face
si on crée une station ici
qu'en 2023 on doit s'interdire de faire
ce type d'aménagement on se rend pas
compte de l'acidence de l'homme sur la
nature la faute de leur blanc dimanche à
13h sur Public Sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre invité est un homme d'honneur et
d'engagement par son parcours et par sa
fonction passée de chef d'état-major des
armées il incarne l'ordre la discipline
la rigueur et l'obéissance pourtant
c'est pas un nom qu'il s'est fait
connaître du grand public un nom à un
président de la République à peine élu
un nom à Emmanuel Macron un acte qui lui
a coûté sa place mais qui lui a aussi
offert une deuxième vie une vie de
conseiller stratégique de chefs
d'entreprise et d'écrivain 4 livres en 5
ans presque un ouvrage par an comme s'il
y avait urgence à parler comme s'il
avait soif d'expression comme s'il
s'était tue trop longtemps fallait-il
que les mots sortent dit-il aujourd'hui
tout ce qu'il s'est retenu de dire avant
étouffant d'occuper un poste qui impose
la réserve posant lui toutes ces
questions bienvenue dans un monde un
regard bienvenu général Pierre de
Villiers merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ici au Sénat dans ce dôme
tournant vous êtes le bienvenu 43 ans de
carrière militaire est-ce que ça empêche
de
tout de même un peu de frustration parmi
tous les militaires j'entends pas
seulement les hauts gradés mais ce
devoir de réserve on appelle l'armée la
grande muette est-ce que ce n'est pas un
peu trop est-ce que d'ailleurs lorsque
vous parlez vous êtes applaudi soutenu
ça veut dire qu'il y a un besoin aussi
d'expression du côté de l'armée oui mais
je crois que notre société finalement
souffre maintenant d'un trop-plein
d'expression et d'information on le voit
avec les réseaux sociaux on le voit dans
la vie quotidienne et que finalement
cette forme de réserve cette forme de
sagesse qu'inspire l'institution
militaire est devenue de plus en plus
populaire et j'en bénéficie en quelque
sorte mais je crois que les militaires
qui rentrent il y en a 25000 par an
c'est énorme 25000 jeunes ils savent à
quoi ils s'engage il s'engage à servir
la France à servir les armées parfois
jusqu'aux sacrifice suprême ils peuvent
aller jusqu'à leur propre vie et ils
s'engagent à cette réserve naturelle à
ce devoir de réserve un droit
d'expression qui est
encadrée et je crois que ils le vivent
ils le vivent très bien alors les armées
ont fait beaucoup de progrès depuis 40
ans
sur cette communication on est loin de
la grande muette d'antan les différentes
opérations que nous avons menées et puis
les relations avec les médias sont en
confiance aujourd'hui mais vous vous
êtes sortis de cette réserve c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui vous a aussi coûté
votre place quelles leçons en avez-vous
tirer
oui moi je quand une fois je suis
toujours resté libre
ma femme mes enfants savaient que du
jour au lendemain je pouvais quitter
l'institution militaire si j'avais un
désaccord suffisamment grave pour ne
plus être capable d'être un serviteur
loyal en confiance et c'est ce qui s'est
passé donc j'ai eu un désaccord avec le
président de la République j'en ai tiré
des conclusions au-dessus de moi vous
savez il y a les armées il y a la France
il y a ceux qu'on a l'honneur de diriger
et j'étais plus en situation de de liens
de confiance avec le président et donc
ça aurait probablement entaché
l'efficacité pour nos armées j'ai
préféré partir et suivant la belle
phrase je ne regrette rien votre premier
livre servir en 2018 vous l'aviez envoyé
avant sa sortie à Emmanuel Macron par
loyauté par courtoisie avez-vous dit il
vous avait répondu qu'il tiendrait
compte de cet ouvrage dans la loi de
programmation militaire ce qu'il a fait
en remontant à 2% du PIB le budget des
armées aujourd'hui le budget des armées
et le deuxième plus gros poste de
dépenses du gouvernement après
l'enseignement 400 milliards d'euros sur
7 ans ont encore été annoncés par le
Président de la République évidemment la
guerre déclenchée par Vladimir Poutine
en Ukraine a rebattu les cartes est-ce
que finalement vous vous dites
aujourd'hui l'histoire vous a donné
raison vous aviez raison d’alerter sur
le budget des armées oui ma personne
enfin vous le verrez au cours de cette
entretien j'essaie quand même d'avoir le
sens du bien commun avant le centre de
mes intérêts personnels je crois que
j'avais raison on peut se le dire une
des choses qui aujourd'hui ne va plus
qui est une des causes de la crise
d'autorité c'est à dire que le pouvoir
l'emporte sur la responsabilité donc en
responsabilité effectivement je pense
que
tristement je voyais juste et depuis
2015 je disais que nous étions dans un
monde install qui n'avait pas trouvé son
nouvel équilibre que les stabilisateurs
automatiques des organisations
internationales n'arrivait plus à
réguler l'ordre international que le
monde était de plus en plus dangereux en
tout cas il était de plus en plus
instable face au terrorisme islamiste
radical face au retour des état s
puissances que j'ai bien senti pressé ce
conflit bien sûr
et
c'était l'origine du désaccord que
j'avais parce que je voyais un décalage
entre les menaces
l'émission qu'on allait donner aux
armées et et les moyens et il faut qu'il
y a cette cohérence et finalement depuis
la chute du mur de Berlin en 89 on a
savouré les délices des dividendes de la
paix simultanément les états puissances
la Chine la Russie la Turquie l'Arabie
saoudite l'Iran l'Inde avait une
stratégie de long terme et réarmée de 5
à 10% par an quand nous nous désarmions
nous les pays européens singulièrement
et donc je voyais haute pression basse
pression et je sentais bien un moment ou
un autre nous allions être décalés d'une
déconnexion d'un pacifisme presque
idéologique d'un refus de voir que les
tensions renaissent je dirais un mélange
du somnambulisme de 14 et de la myopie
de 39 toujours le même phénomène
l'incapacité à voir loin en fait une des
difficultés aujourd'hui pour nos
dirigeants c'est de voir loin je le vois
dans l'entreprise dans les associations
dans tous les domaines aujourd'hui dans
les tiré vers le temps très court
l'urgence il y a même plus de priorité
on est dans l'urgence et on est plus
dans la stratégie l'art du temps long
alors nous dans l'armée on est formé à
Saint-Cyr dans la stratégie on est dans
la tactique on n'est pas dans la
question quoi ou la question pourquoi on
est toujours dans la question comment en
l'occurrence il y a une urgence en ce
moment j'imagine que vous suivez de près
les questions d'envoi d'armes à
l'Ukraine la France envoie des cadences
César pas de Charles Leclerc Alain Bauer
qu'un spécialiste des questions de
sécurité de défense a récemment dit ceci
on ne les a pas les chars il n'y a pas
de stock le général De Villiers a été
remercié par Macron pour avoir dit la
vérité il a raison on les a pas les
chats on n'a pas le matériel
on avait 600 chars il y a 20 ans à peine
on en a plus de 200 on a 220 sherlocker
sur les 220 il y en a qui sont
actuellement en réparation donc quand
vous alignez
ceux qui sont vraiment disponibles ce
qu'on appelle bon de guerre je vois pas
ce qu'on pourrait donner comme Charles
Leclerc aux Ukrainiens ou alors vraiment
on donne tout non je crois que nous
avons un problème de modèle d'armée nous
étions dimensionnés avec un modèle
global c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas fait
d'impasse mais échantillonnaire et nous
étions capables de mener ce qu'on a fait
depuis 20 ans des opérations de guerre
mais pas une guerre une guerre c'est
long ça dure et ça use et il faut donc
avoir cette épaisseur que nous avons
perdu il faut des stocks de munitions il
faut de la logistique il faut des gens
formés entraîner et les effectifs on
voit bien que ça va être le principal
problème de Ukrainiens ça sera pas le
matériel ça sera les gens pour servir le
matériel et puis il faut bien sûr les
équipements au bon endroit au bon moment
donc c'est un modèle d'armée c'est très
compliqué mais ça ne se fait pas en six
mois en un an ou en deux ans un modèle
d'armée se prévoit à 10 15 ans et c'est
cette peut-être cette anticipation que
nous avons perdu pendant toutes ces
années depuis la chute du mur de Berlin
notamment alors on est allé
effectivement en augmentant depuis 2017
mais pas suffisamment par rapport à ce
que moi je pensais qu'il fallait faire
on va poursuivre cet échange avec un
document que j'ai à vous proposer que je
vais vous donner en main propre et
d'écrire pour les gens qui nous écoutent
c'est un document délivré par nos
partenaires dans cette émission les
Archives nationales il s'agit d'une
photo du général de Gaulle prise fin
juin 1960 lors d'une visite à la caserne
des Célestins à Paris siège de
l'état-major de la garde républicaine de
Gaulle est alors Président il porte son
uniforme de général un militaire à la
tête du pays qui portait le costume
publiquement dans les rues de France
est-ce que d'après vous ça passerait
encore aujourd'hui ce type d'image des
Français supporteraient l'image d'un
président en uniforme général ou au
contraire ça pourrait les rassurer
ce qui s'est fait en 1960 peut-être
aujourd'hui me semblerait décalé en tout
cas moi je ne me pose pas ces questions
là vous avez vu que l'uniforme est
devenu presque un instrument politique
aujourd'hui quand on le soutient on est
de droite quand on ne le soutient pas on
est de gauche vous voyez un peu cette il
atmosphère je vois surtout que l'armée
est peut-être la dernière institution
qui rassemble le pays
et je le vois parce que je le sens vous
savez je fais deux déplacements en
province à peu près par semaine pour la
promotion de mon livre et pour mes
activités de conseil auprès des jeunes
notamment
moi dans les salles j'ai la France dans
sa diversité dans sa diversité sociale
professionnelle
intergénérationnel
l'armée finalement
est devenu en quelque sorte à certains
égards le pompier de la République et
c'est vrai des clients problèmes on
appelle l'armée ou on raisonne armée
donc elle attire elle ne repousse pas
d'après ce que vous ressentez d'après ce
que vous observez moi je suis rentré
Saint-Cyr en 75 c'était la grande époque
de l'antimétarisme post 68 heures et
aujourd'hui on est très loin de tout ça
notamment depuis les attentats moi je
crois que les attentats ont constitué un
tournant important notamment vis-à-vis
des jeunes cet engagement cette élan
pour servir le pays pour la protection
de la France et des Français je crois
que ça a été un facteur déclenchant et
puis plus ça va plus les jeunes ont
besoin de souffle d'engagement de raison
d'être de quelque chose qui les dépasse
et finalement l'armée qui n'a pas
fondamentalement changé sa colonne
vertébrale
offre tout ça
vous verriez vous Président je vous pose
la question parce que vous avez été
testé dans les sondages pour la
présidentielle et vos scores étaient
bons près de 25% des sondés vous voyez
bien à l'Elysée ça vous a tenté de dire
oui de tenter l'aventure des gens vous
ont écrit ils ont dit mon général on
croit à l'armée prenez le pouvoir c'est
quelqu'un comme vous qui nous faut à la
tête du pays oui alors moi j'ai toujours
annoncé la couleur de manière la plus
claire possible simplement effectivement
beaucoup de gens disent ça je suis
arrêté dans la rue régulièrement par des
gens qui qui sont toujours très gentils
et très respectueux et vous dites
l'armée attire l'armée attire l'armée
rassure oui oui incontestablement mais
moi je ne ferai pas de carrière
politique je l'ai dit plus clairement je
suis un officier français j'ai choisi de
servir la France sous les armes et mon
engagement d'aujourd'hui après ma
calamitaire c'est de transmettre ce que
l'armée m'a appris ce que le football
m'a apprise que ma famille m'a appris
tout ce que j'ai appris de transmettre
notamment à la jeunesse et puis un peu
aux entreprises dans cette période
difficile à turbulente que nous vivons
mais c'est déjà beaucoup transmettre ça
me suffit et je n'ai pas cette vocation
politique j'ai beaucoup d'admiration
pour les hommes politiques c'est pas
facile de servir la France dans la
politique aujourd'hui ce n'est ce n'est
pas mon but ce n'est pas mon charisme il
existe encore des gens sincères je ne
suis pas un billard à quatre bandes et
je suis au premier degré j'essaie de le
rester authentique c'est peut-être ça
qui fait que les gens m'aiment bien
parce que souvent après un propos il me
disent ah vous êtes différent des autres
vous êtes inspirant Hashim bah tant
mieux si je suis inspirant et puis
finalement vous avez l'impression de
croire en ce que vous dites alors ça se
dit aussi en creux ça veut dire que
beaucoup de gens parlent et donnent
l'impression de ne pas croire en ce
qu'ils disent c'est authenticité ce sens
de l'engagement de vous est pas venu par
hasard votre père Jacques le joli des
milliers de centignons a été officiers
il a servi sous le commandement du
colonel De Lattre de Tassigny pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale il a été fait
prisonnier au camp de Lubeck parce qu'il
avait sauvé un officier juif il a
d'ailleurs reçu la médaille de la
Résistance est-ce qu'entrée dans l'armée
finalement et faire carrière militaire
était une évidence pour vous même une
obligation est-ce que vous avez senti
que vous aviez le choix ou pas alors le
choix totalement
que la carrière de mon père m'a
influencé de la même manière que c'est
vrai que le père qui a son le fils qui a
son père docteur ou cordonnier artisans
etc on est influencé par le milieu dans
lequel on vit c'est vrai que mon père
m'a raconté sa carrière militaire de
Lattre j'ai d'ailleurs une admiration
sans borne pour Delattre qui était un
grand chef d'unité avec l'amalgame c'est
quand même extraordinaire oui
certainement que ça a joué après on
reste pas 43 ans dans une institution
pour faire plaisir à son père ou à ses
parents et j'y ai trouvé mon
épanouissement personnel évidemment
elle a eu aux jeunes garçons que vous
étiez au jeune homme que vous étiez que
lui diriez vous avant qu'il ne se lance
dans la vie
je lui dirai d'essayer de réussir dans
sa vie mais que ça ne suffit pas réussir
dans sa vie avoir une belle profession
avoir des diplômes avoir des
responsabilités c'est important et ça il
faut travailler pour ça mais je lui
dirai surtout de réussir sa vie cet
équilibre entre le corps l'intelligence
le cœur l'esprit
ce vrai bonheur finalement moi j'étais
chef d'être un major des armées j'ai
réussi dans ma vie c'est pas ce dont je
suis le plus fier selon fut le plus fier
c'est mon équilibre entre ma vie
professionnelle et ma vie personnelle
j'ai ma femme mes 6 enfants ma famille
mes convictions mes activités mais
hobbies le football par exemple et j'ai
gardé cet équilibre c'est ça donc je
suis le plus fier c'est ce que je dirais
aux jeunes réussissez votre vie ne
cherchez pas tout toujours à réussir
dans votre vie ça ne suffira pas à votre
bonheur j'évoquais en introduction les
quatre livres que vous avez écrit servir
qu'est-ce qu'un chef l'équilibre est un
courage parole d'honneur parlons de
celui-ci parole d'honneur l'être à la
jeunesse dont vous ne cessez de parler
depuis le début de cet entretien paru
chez Fayard elle a beaucoup de travail
cette je